Record.
Hi sweeties.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for.
Is that me?
Click on the link for the flashlight and
enter in the code name,
Rogan.
He's a flashlight,
flashlight,
flesh,
flesh.
How dare you did?
I said,
well,
I didn't need a flashlight.
I don't know.
I think I said flesh.
I'm a little too few people out there.
I'm a little too high to be doing this
commercial.
Maybe I'm too high and I heard it.
Flashlight.
Look,
the fleshlight is an excellent product.
This is for real.
I'm going to stray off the script.
You know,
let's get everybody needs masturbation.
That shit's important is important.
It seems ridiculous.
It's very embarrassing,
but it is sexual maintenance and it's
important and you shoot way bigger
loads,
in my opinion with the flashlight,
that it's powerful.
How?
Because your girlfriend gets mad at it.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Now I've lost at least more than one
flashlight just vanish.
It got thrown away,
thrown away.
Oh my goodness.
Fascinating.
Is that no pleasure?
Only me.
Can.
Pleasure.
Not even like a fake part of a person.
I think I pattern,
but I think it's more that she's
embarrassed that I've got a can with an
asshole poking at it.
Listen,
this is the beginning of the show.
Hit the button pitches.
Duncan trussell's here.
We've already had a podcast and a half
before we even got started and we might
be too high to talk in public.
Just give it a fucking country.
No,
the country Tryezz,
but God damn.
I wish I had it in me.
I wish I had some country work ethic,
con stance or something.
You know,
country workout.
Fuck you.
People talk about a guy that's got a
country work ethic automatically.
You'll you,
you know,
you mean a man.
Want to admire them?
Yeah.
Awesome dude.
He could just shut his fucking mouth and
for some hay around.
That's right.
There's something about that.
That's admirable,
right?
Isn't it?
Sure.
It's amazing.
It's like some wild west type movie
shit.
Yeah.
That seems like a great life guy who
gets up early in the morning,
just fucking milks cows till he can't
walk anymore and the day goes to sleep.
Something admirable about.
Have you ever found an attorney,
Joe?
Yes.
I think I have on fear factor.
Pretty sure a goat one.
Squeeze it.
I don't know if I did it.
I might be imagining this was so long
ago.
Um,
we had people suck on goat tits.
They had actually suck on it.
It was very phallic.
It was really weird to watch like girls
sucking on this tit like sucking milk
off.
This looks like a black deck.
It looks like a deformed,
like a short fat black Dick and these
girls and these girls were suck at all
of these things.
Pulling milk out of guys were to,
you know,
it was,
it was.
Wow.
That goat is experiencing what is
essentially a ufo abduction.
It's mind cannot process what's
happening.
Whereas they're used to getting milked
apparently because they milk them every
day.
You know,
they squeeze on them.
Yeah.
But if you imagine having just like
fading on you and you don't know what
they're doing.
So demonic,
right?
Yeah.
Trapped in a cage,
right.
Attached by color.
I think there were attached by a chain
trying to make sense on.
I mean they must in some way be trying
to process what's happening.
Oh,
and you know what?
They were elevated as well.
How weird was that?
They were up on the platform so that
people could get out of them with their
mouth.
They didn't have to go under him.
If I'm pretty sure,
if I remember that correctly,
I might be imagining that as well,
but I remember.
Imagine I remember being there thinking
how bizarre it was.
Just people are sucking on these animal
parts on TV,
you know?
It feels real.
If you ever feel cow one.
I just wonder if there's a lot of
farmers,
but it feels real like it feels like
you're holding something.
That's the only thing that you've ever
felt like that before is your Dick.
So it feels like it just feels like a.
it's like a flashlight for men.
When you mean a delta.
Yeah.
This fucking strains that we drink the
milk out of other animals.
So we make them make milk and then we
drank it and we sell it and it's super
common milk.
Totally normal.
Yeah.
It's like we're parasites or cow
parasite.
We extract some,
some they're fluid and we sell it and we
add weird shit till we put chocolate in
it,
but apparently a lot of people believe
that eating dairy is not healthy for the
human body and that you'll feel better.
Your energy levels will be better if you
just cut dairy out of your life.
I've heard that from so many people.
There's no way it can't be true,
but milk is delicious and so as ice
cream and you can go fuck yourself.
I liked cheese,
you know,
I'm not cutting dairy out.
I just went to a.
I just went to Paris and she got super
stoned.
And how'd you get stoned in Paris?
I'll talk about it after the podcast.
You don't want to mention on the
podcast?
No.
Good move.
Yeah,
just a friend out in Paris.
Wow.
That's lucky break.
But uh,
but weed is illegal and parents,
how illegal is it?
I don't know.
I was standing next to someone openly
smoking hash in the subway.
So really?
Yeah.
So I don't know how illegal.
I don't think anyone.
I don't know.
I have no idea,
but I hadn't eaten there yet and I was
super stoned and it was the first time
I'd ever eaten like French cheese and I
almost passed out because it tasted so
good.
I swear to God I got a momentary vertigo
or it's like I've been eating prison
cafeteria food for my entire life
because the food over there is better.
Food in Paris is better.
It comes straight from the countryside
right now though.
Hundreds and thousands of dudes tweeting
for all over the country going,
why don't you fucking move?
I would if I could really.
I've always thought they had the worst
food until he.
He said this because I always.
I worked at a French restaurant once and
it was the worst food ever.
Like the lobster bisque or something
like that was the only thing that I
thought was decent on the whole menu.
What is it like a low end restaurant or
was it a nice place?
French place?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm not really familiar.
I'm not as much as much of a food
efficient auto that I could tell you
what French food really is.
I know there's a place down the street
from here I really liked.
That's supposedly French because they
have fog law.
That's the French way of saying,
right,
this duck liver,
it's delicious.
It's one of the rude as fuck they.
They were the mouth.
Fuck this.
Poor goose.
It's terrible.
I mean their mouth.
Fuck this goose and force feed them.
It's kind of crazy.
It's a.
it's a horrible,
horrible thing.
What is it?
Their liver?
No,
it's their liver mixed in with the shit
base spray into them and it like
flavors.
That's what it is,
right?
It flavors the liver so that it tastes
really good,
but it's so good.
Here's the weird thing.
That's the guy.
I think this is going to piss everybody
off if they're not already mad about me
saying French fruit's better,
but it is better.
Like it's defined better.
Like what?
What makes it better?
They just use more butters that it's
more like I don't give no,
but I mean in France,
I've got to imagine it's it just on
another level of like it's more,
it's more intense.
It's like.
I'm trying to think of a great way to
explain it.
It's like the volume is turned up a
little bit more on it.
It's flavor wise.
The flavor's better.
It's just,
it's like they like the way they cook
it.
The place that we went to,
they were cooking.
We ordered this rib platter for two and
they cook this giant slab of meat on an
open fire,
like above a fireplace and you can watch
it in the restaurant and the restaurant
feels like something out of the 16
hundreds or something.
Do you know why it feels like that?
Because it's been around since the 16
hundreds.
Like everything.
There's old,
old,
so it's like you're in this place where
so many human lives have happened and
I'm not saying that's why the food
tastes better,
but it's your insurance.
It's so good,
man.
It was really good.
Or kind of make a word one.
One thing that I never appreciated,
I think before watch sort of watching
that no reservations show was that that
food for the preparation of food is
really an art form.
It really,
truly is an art form.
I mean I kind of knew that abstractly
and I always like appreciated good
chefs,
but until I watched that show not,
you see that guy's passion,
how he describes food,
how um,
how uh,
how addictive it is.
You know,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Not Addictive.
It's like,
it's,
it just gets you hungry like it,
it starts like the way he describes
things,
like I never get more hungry than when
I'm watching that shit.
It's like you realize that people are
really bad ass chefs.
All these guys,
they're all like,
they all have ideas and thoughts and
like a,
a method to how they prepare things and,
and it's,
it's so fascinating that it's just to
maximize the impact that it has on the
pallet and it's just strange art form
the art form of flavor.
And I never really appreciated that
until I watched that show.
And then when then you what you see like
a really well prepared dish and you're
like,
wow,
that guy just fucked me up with some
crazy crab with squid ink pasta.
And you realize that like these
creations of textures and combinations
of flavors,
it really is a bad ass art form.
I never appreciated it before.
Yeah,
yeah.
And you get this when you taste
something really good like that,
you get a glimpse at how there's like
this spectrum of sense gratification and
some people in some parts of the world
and figured out ways to hit the higher
ends up.
So if you're only experiencing life at
this one spectrum of it,
then when you do get something super
high end like that,
it's really intense.
It's just uh,
it's amazing to think people eat like
that every day.
And also the weird thing about a lot of
people in Paris,
they fucking eat so much and they eat
all day long.
It seems like everything there is about
eating or going out to eat with your
friends.
And it's this very serious ritual.
Like when you go to a restaurant,
it has the same energy of like you feel
like you're in an air traffic control
tower.
People are eating in the serious way.
It's like a,
like they're taking in an art or
listening to a symphony and some of
these restaurants,
not all of them,
but some of them it's intense and
there's like four waiters,
they're dressed like super formally.
There's kids being trained since they
were like 15 to be waiters and so it's
this cultural,
it's embedded into their culture and
they've really refined it and it's
really fucking cool,
but French people that are the ones that
you don't see fat people there,
they're eating all the fucking time,
but most of them are thin.
Most of them seem like they're in shape.
It's really weird.
How do they do that?
People say because there's no
preservatives in the food they eat,
like food that comes straight from the
countryside.
That's what people say.
I mean,
I'd heard all this stuff by the way I'd
heard it before I went.
I read it.
The food,
there's better.
People are like thin people are living
life and I was extremely skeptical,
link,
whatever.
It's that Buddhist quote,
I think I've said it on here.
Some people will tell you this place is
better than that place.
This country is better than this
country.
There's smarter people here than there,
but I say to you,
the whole world is on fire.
Everywhere you go.
People are consumed with the same fears
and worries and it's all the same.
The Buddha did not eat ribs and fucking
Paris because that place is different.
It's fucking nice man.
For subway signs.
They all look like the lettering,
the font.
They use an absence bottles like,
yeah,
it's fucking trippy and cool.
And I'll,
I'll shut up about Paris because I might
sound like an Asshole,
but we,
uh,
you know about the catacombs of Paris.
No,
you were describing this to me.
This is the most scariest Shit I've ever
seen in my life that did it.
I did not know existed.
And there's more than one.
I've soft photos once of a church,
but just explain to everybody what it
is.
So underneath Paris basically,
and I don't know the exact history
behind this,
but what happened is I think because of
the black plague,
everyone starts dying.
They're having these mass die offs and
they were.
They ran out of room and the cemeteries.
So they had to dig up all the bones from
the cemetery surrounding Paris and they
took them under Paris into these
limestone quarries and created these
things called Ossuarys,
which are these open air crips and
someone has gone and basically.
So to get there,
you go down these winding steps that go
down and down and down and down and down
and down and down and down and down and
down to a point where you start feeling
like you're going crazy because you just
keep seeing more steps and more steps
and more steps and more steps in your
mind.
Starts saying you are going deep,
deep underground.
Like we're talking like out of breath on
the stairmaster steps like way down to
the quarries under the city and you sort
of walk around and then suddenly you
come out and do hallways of bones.
Just yellowed old French bonds that
someone is stacked into a patterns like
crucifixes and it looks like the Texas
chainsaw massacre house when you went in
the movie where they have bone
sculptures everywhere.
It's like that.
They've just.
Someone just took like a shitload of
femurs and it's like,
I think I could make a crucifix out of
this and like.
So there's a cross in the middle.
There's stacks of skulls.
They say there's 9 million skeletons
down there,
9 million.
So 9 million lives are completely
anonymous now.
No one knows who the fuck they are.
All you see is just,
there's no names,
there's not a wall listing who's down
there.
It's just row upon row upon row of
skulls and skulls and I swear to God,
it's got to be the worst job on the
planet.
I pass this French kid whose job is to
sit in a lawn chair down there and
observed people to make sure they don't
steal bones.
And I walked by the kid and he was like
hail and sick because it's damp down
there and it kinda sounded like he was
talking to himself and French.
He kind of seemed out of his mind.
He just sits in bones all day.
Best place to rape ever though,
right?
If you're going to rape and murder
somebody,
take them down there.
That'd be perfect.
Well,
it gets weirder,
so as it turns out under Paris,
the catacombs at the are in.
That's only a fraction of the catacombs.
There is miles and miles and miles of
wining catacombs.
One of our waiters told us that people
go down there and they get lost and they
find them down there and they've starved
to death in the and catacombs fucking
die.
Crazy.
Last.
You go down there and the dark,
the flashlight runs out.
No one's coming down there and you're
fucking so much.
Gets even weirder.
These fucking French police.
It's on the Internet and I'm just
freaking out and thinking about dying
that way.
Could you imagine your fucking slash
light goes out and it's so far down like
it's like a basement of earth that just
that last moment and then nothing.
Blackness.
You start,
you would start hearing,
start hearing things,
start seeing things.
You probably don't send people down
there looking for folks.
No,
not some.
Not some French mime who got depressed
and decided he was going to go down and
take a break in the category.
So is it open to anyone yet that the
Parisian teenagers have their own
entrances and they bring turntables and
speakers down there and have dance
parties?
Oh my God.
So fucking cool.
We want to go down there and take
Iowasca with you,
Joe.
So we're not going to say,
could you imagine what a terrific
combination that would you adopt,
right?
Yeah.
Well you would definitely never be seen
again,
right?
You would probably just be absorbed with
the energy of what it must have been
like to see millions of people just
right in front of you by some incurable
disease that was inescapable and you had
just had a hope that some of the
genetics would carry on it.
Some people would be able to live
through this shit.
If you ever get serious about your life,
that is a.
A cure is the c nine millions goals to
Emr.
Come on,
man.
Does it really make you less serious
about your life?
It just,
you know,
it just lets you know.
Yeah,
it lets you know that there's,
we're,
we're very fortunate that shit's going
this way.
We're very fortunate.
We were born in 2000.
We're alive in 2011.
We're very fortunate.
You know,
just a little while ago,
stuff was terrible.
You know,
I joke around about being on stage,
like when we were in Philly and I was
going,
do you know why the streets are so
narrow around here?
Because there were made by people
writing fucking horses.
Like wrap your head around that.
This city was designed by people who
thought,
well,
we just need a place to put the horses.
This is where the horses are going to
run.
Like everybody got around it.
I'll fucking city on horses.
Well there's that.
You know,
there,
there's this thing I just read about
this,
a famous,
I think he was an obstetrician and he
died in a mental asylum.
It was unready.
He died in a mental asylum.
This is way back.
I don't know the exact time,
but it was when they still believed in
the humors of the body,
their idea of the way the body worked
was based on,
you know,
bloodletting and they didn't know they
thought
they were.
They didn't know that flies came from
fly eggs.
They thought there was something called
spontaneous generation where if you had
the right elements in one place,
it would produce a fly.
He,
they didn't know there were eggs.
So they had these really fascinating
ways of understanding the universe.
What year was this?
I don't know the exact year.
If you look up spontaneous generation,
it'll pop up the year that they believed
this.
But,
um,
there was a obstetrician who suddenly
came up with this crazy idea.
He thought that if doctors wash their
hands between handling,
like doing an autopsy or handling a dead
body and delivering a baby,
then maybe the mothers wouldn't die as
much as they were dying of this
infection called fluorosis.
So he's like,
we should start maybe washing her hands
guys,
after you handle the a rotting corpse
and then put your hand in that lady's
Pussy.
Why don't you wash your hands and um,
doctors were like,
you're a fucking lunatic.
You think washing,
you think if we wash our hands after we
handle a corpse and touch a woman's
open,
open dilated pussy that it's going to
keep her from getting the infections
they've been getting.
A gentleman's hands are always clean.
That's what the doctor said.
No joke.
So this guy,
I tried all these experiments and he
like,
he dropped the death rate and one of
these like wards where women are giving
birth to one percent where it was 30
percent and other places and he kept
talking.
You've got to wash your hands.
You wash it with this kind of chemical
mix and the people won't die.
You should wash your hands,
germs are getting into people.
But they didn't.
I don't think they knew what germs were.
Anyway,
the guy died,
I think it was.
We didn't think it was germs.
Just poison
with evil,
which was.
I don't know the explanation,
but it's really interesting because you
could,
it's kind of logical.
You could see why they would think that,
but they couldn't accept the idea that
there was microscopic things floating
around,
like even though I guess you could see
them in a microscope for some reason,
they really wanted to deny this in the
same way.
Now when you talk about the idea that
there might be an extra dimensional
aliens,
there are interdimensional beings that
you're seeing through the lens of a
psychedelic.
You tell that to anyone or most people
in there like you are fucking crazy.
You new age.
Fucking read it.
Anyway,
so the point is the guy died in an
insane asylum for suggesting people
washing,
wash their hands.
That's how dirty everything was back
then.
That's how it effected everything was
done in insane.
This guy out of his mind and as you
know,
towards the end of his life,
they said he got dementia,
but I think it was just because he knew
that he had discovered this thing,
that he proved he could save so many
lives and no one will listen to UNC.
Could you imagine,
dude,
if you were an advanced human and you
were stuck in an advanced age that just
refused to change,
could you imagine if you were a
scientist from 2011 and then all of a
sudden you found yourself in the middle
of the Spanish inquisition?
You were.
Everyone was ridiculous and people were
just killing people and it was just
insanity.
He couldn't talk to anybody.
Just religious fanaticism completely out
of control and murder and all kinds of
crazy shit was going on.
Could you imagine?
Yeah.
That was your reality.
All of a sudden,
religious fanaticism,
violent wars raging everywhere.
Talla,
Tarian,
presidents,
corporations running everything.
This Michele Bachmann lady won the Iowa
Straw poll.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
He's a fucking dominatrix public and
boys like to get spanked.
We are living in fascinating times.
It's when it's ripples like this,
like when you hear things like this to
me,
they look like little little ripples on
your universe,
like wake up,
pay attention.
There's a lot more dumb people that you
think,
oh,
more painfully stupid people in this
country.
A lot of them,
tons of them,
they can't see that she's dumb because
they're way dumber than her.
They're way dumber than her.
They have no idea.
She's dumb.
They think she's got a good message and
they they.
They don't mind her crazy eyes.
They don't see the crazy eyes.
They don't see the gay husband.
They don't see him.
He seems like a Nice Fella.
He's praying,
yeah,
gay away.
Grave.
The gay away we'll go.
We'll go to bunch of them and hold them
hands.
We're going to pray in their underwear,
were hugging each other,
shooting loads in their pants.
This is a ridiculous institution.
You have to learn how to shoot a load in
front of men without wanting men.
What is it so hard for people to accept
that people are gay?
What do you give a fuck?
They're gay.
So what?
Let them enjoy it.
What do you.
What if it doesn't affect you?
As long as they're not trying to fuck
you.
Who cares what?
I don't get it.
It doesn't make any sense.
You're going to pray it away where
you're going.
The gangway prelude,
but you gotta see gotTa.
You gotta understand that relationship
because I think about this relationship
between Michelle Bachmann and her
husband who was clearly gay,
clearly runs what is.
He's running a.
that's a sex dungeon,
Brian.
That data
brian impression is really not that far
off.
Know he's so unbelievably gay stuff.
Seems Gay.
Hey,
say Scott,
I don't know that he's gay for sure,
but it might not be productive.
You know that he's running a sex
dungeon,
a sex dungeon,
you know,
he is absolutely.
Pray away.
The Gay Clinic,
that's a sex dungeon.
Yeah,
for submissive.
Good gay guys.
Submissive.
Gay guys go in there.
They go and it's like a fetish.
It's a,
it's a,
it's like a fetish situation.
It's like these get married,
gay guys go into this place where an
expert says that he's going to use
religion to help them overcome being
gay.
The expert happens to seem like super
gay,
like super.
Like he should be on the front of his
own float in a gay pride parade,
holding sparklers and feel like,
I don't know,
wearing like whether a bra or something.
That seems right,
but he's in a suit now and he's talking
to you in that stereotypical voice.
He's saying,
we can overcome this thing.
James,
I need you to tell me though,
every gay sexual encounter that you've
ever had.
You know,
that's part of it.
Okay.
I'll tell Ya.
You gotta hear it out,
Talia.
Yeah.
Once I blew 17 guys at a bare party in
New Jersey.
Oh,
they alone.
When this is happening,
is it
dark?
Yeah,
it's dim.
It's dim in there.
There's candles of Jesus.
Candace,
I guarantee that place is covered in
pictures of the sick erotic Jesus,
the six pack.
Jesus.
You ever seen those where Jesus has
painted with a six pack on the Cross,
like a Jersey shore situation happening,
but he's getting cruised.
Whoa.
There's tons out there.
It's supposed to be starvation,
but we look at it as like,
wow,
that's like hardcore crunches.
That's not starvation,
but what happens is a lot of these
people,
back when they were painting those
pictures were just artists who are
getting paid by the church and they
needed to make money,
but they liked the male form and so they
were painting like they are making Jesus
hot sex.
Jesus erotic Jesus Christianity's true.
Christianity is a lot of Christianity's
fucking s and and think about it.
The son of God comes down to the world
and what happens?
He tells the truth and he gets spanked
and a crown of thorns and whipped with
lashes and nailed to a fucking cross and
everyone's into it like,
did you see the passion of the Christ?
That's an snm movie,
man.
I've been to the SNM clubs,
tie guys up to fucking crucifixes and
whip him there all the time,
but I like black Jesus better.
The whole theory of them.
Yeah.
What is the black Jesus theory,
but because Jesus was supposedly
sephardic,
wasn't it?
Isn't that.
Wasn't that the idea?
I don't know who's hotter,
who's hotter.
I think it's what I think it goes from
is that everything has to start from
black.
Not White,
you know,
I think it's fascinating that people
want to a lay claim to something that
people want to like that black people
would go like Jesus was black,
like,
like it makes some handle that makes
your life if Jesus was even real,
but it makes your life today in 2011.
Like you can lay claim to that.
Like we did that we did.
How annoying is that?
Like you lay,
click like Italians,
like hey with Allianz,
you know,
we built that,
we did that.
You know,
It's not really we dude,
here's we really in this group together
here,
black Jesus,
babies lack a child.
Wow,
let's find Jesus Dot Com.
Well hate man.
That's just as likely black.
Jesus is just as likely as white.
Jesus both of were just so squirrely
and so you're just supposed to believe
that the dude came back from the dead
and the and that anybody would write
that he would come back from the dead.
Anything else that you would read from
them would not be equally ridiculous
because we understand dad.
Now we understand that now and you're,
you're,
you're saying that we must discount at
all scientific knowledge ever just
because there's an ancient book that
says some some stuff and if you go along
with it,
you have to just assume that this was a
one time thing and that this one time,
these amazing,
miraculous things that defy science
happened and we just have to assume that
these people who barely could write shit
down.
We're super accurate about it.
Like it's ridiculous.
Let's even think one step before that,
which is the religion that they've built
around this thing that based on all
scientific evidence is possibly a myth.
They have their religion.
They based around this character.
Jesus is nowhere close to the things the
character said in the book that they
read.
Jesus didn't walk around saying,
you need to go to church.
Here's an idea.
Go to build a church and every Sunday go
to the church and sit down and an
uncomfortable seat and read prayers
prewritten from people that you barely
understand and then give 10 percent of
your income to this group of people and
just trust that they're going to use it
in the right way.
Jesus never said anything like that in
the,
in the,
uh,
New Testament.
If you read this stuff,
mostly the idea of the thing seems to be
if you love the people around you as
much as you can,
and if you're tuned into God or the love
force of the universe and you love that
too,
then you are going to have a great life.
That seems to be the message.
You don't need a priest.
You don't need a church.
You don't need anybody.
You don't have to follow the rules of
the time he was,
you know,
in Judaism there are very strict rules
about how you're supposed to live.
And he was saying,
we don't have to follow these rules.
I don't have to do anything that you're
saying.
I have my own direct connection with the
super intelligent,
super abundance of the universe and
that's all I need,
and so then they killed them.
So you've got that and then what builds
up around it?
Fucking Michelle Bachman,
pray away the gay,
just like Jesus want to.
Jesus didn't want somebody sticking
their technical and somebody excretory,
a tube and the bid.
They.
Jesus wanted people straight.
Only fucking vaginas.
The creator of the universe.
It gives them a migraine headache to
know on this planet.
People are sticking their fucking
genitals and the other people,
the assholes.
That's how does that get trends?
How does that get translated from
basically the first hippie?
Love each other.
Tune into this superintelligence.
It's really creepy and weird.
Well,
whenever you have some obscure,
I don't want to say obscure,
but very difficult to put
into modern words statement like
whenever you read any of the any
chapters of the Bible,
any,
any passages,
and he thinks that people quote all the
time.
There's a lot of the stuff.
You'll read it and you go,
well,
what exactly does that mean?
Like what is,
you know,
trying to back up and,
and decipher that into modern language.
What was it originally,
you know,
I mean,
we know it all came from ancient Hebrew
and then they kind of take it from
ancient Hebrew to Latin Greek.
Like what the fuck was,
what would you know?
It's totally different language.
What was the original meaning behind it?
Well,
you got like,
but you know,
I used to,
when I was in college,
take lsd and I read the New Testament
and it was the most awesome psychedelic
thing ever because you're reading it and
you're thinking like this.
No matter what this is,
it's shaped so much of society.
These words are shaped so many people's
lives.
And so just from that alone,
it's super psychedelic.
But what did it come from?
What's the original language?
What's it based on?
There's all these awesome ideas,
you know,
because there's a lot of books of the,
in the gospels that didn't make it in to
the final cut that are equally valid and
are far more esoteric and uh,
have like really weird ideas.
I've read stuff that it's based in like
this form of religion called Gnosticism,
which I don't know too much about.
I've heard that it's like some weird
desert called called these scenes or
that it's somehow the formulation of all
these different desert mysticisms kind
of merging into the,
you know,
they embodied it in the form of this
person to transmit this bigger
information about the idea that they're,
you know,
we're all children of some super
intelligence and that if we give up our,
um,
greed and selfishness and love other
people,
like we love ourselves,
then that would create like a,
you know,
if everyone did that,
then we would be living on this would be
utopia.
We will be in some kind of super
communist,
mystical,
spiritual state where everyone's
completely connected with each other.
Like imagine really feeling about
everyone around you the same way you
feel about yourself.
It means don't differentiate other
people from your life.
No more differentiation.
We're all the same.
We're all completely connected.
We're all children of this universe and
so we should treat each other love.
Yeah.
That doesn't work with society though,
unfortunately.
Like we would do,
they would have to be some gigantic
event that got rid of get rid of
currency or got rid of the idea of
competing for currency because until p,
as long as people are still competing,
competing for job positions,
competing their company against other
companies,
and as long as there's capitalism going
on that,
that push for money,
that push to make money,
that's.
You're always going to get this same
kind of Douchey,
cunty,
chimp behavior.
You know,
it's a competition.
There's a,
it's obvious way.
Obvious that most people are working way
harder than is both healthy and is
desirable.
They're working ridiculous hours and
pushing harder than ever because they
need more money.
They want more money,
they need more money.
It's like there's a drive,
like a fucking wild machine behind it,
you know?
That's as long as that's there.
Fuck man.
How are you going to get everybody to
just just have resources available?
You're going to trust people to work.
You're going to trust everyone to put in
their share.
Like all of us are going to trust all of
us and what do we do when someone
doesn't.
Even if we're supposed to love them,
we love ourselves.
We just supposed to let them just fuck
everything up all around them and let
them go into super sabotaged spin out
mode where they destroy everything in
their vicinity and nobody stops him from
doing that because that's like a spoiled
child.
We've seen that
before.
Yeah.
That's the other crazy aspect of
Christianity.
Is it ultra pacifism?
It's like super positivism and the
message of the thing was supposed to be,
look,
this being that they're killing is the
physical manifestation of the universe.
It could do a,
could fight back.
It could shoot lasers out of its eyes.
It's a superhero,
but it's letting itself.
I don't know.
I'm calling Jesus in net.
Whatever he is,
he's a wedding.
It's a wedding itself.
Get killed to give a message,
and the message is this.
There are some things that are more
important than life and if you want to
get caught up in this dimension and you
want to save your body,
you want to try to save your body,
go ahead.
It's going to die no matter what.
You're dead meat.
It's like there's no way you're going to
make it through this dimension.
No one,
no one makes it out alive.
Whatever Jim Morrison said,
we all know and gets out of this alive.
We all die.
So if you want to like focus and fixate
on protecting yourself,
fine.
But the idea is like the,
you're supposed to completely surrender
to this energy.
Right?
And then when in regard and once you
really make that move,
which they say is an act of faith,
which I mean,
I,
by the way,
this is purely speculation.
I have not given my heart to Jesus,
but I am.
I think about,
you know,
what would happen if you did just become
completely everyone.
Yeah.
What would that be?
I mean obviously it's not possible,
right?
But why?
But why and who would make cars and how
could there be competition?
How is there this,
you know,
how would there be any form of
capitalism?
The way we have it right now,
how?
How would our society,
the monetary system,
how would it be set up the way that it
wouldn't be?
It couldn't be.
It's impossible.
It's impossible
exists.
The church couldn't exist.
Society couldn't.
Yeah,
so how would we revamp it?
How would we,
how would we put it all into
perspective?
Put it all into order.
How would we ensure that everyone
follows along with it?
We're not.
Is that like a net?
Is that next stage of evolution is the
next stage of evolution.
The idea that people have gotten to a
point technologically where we can start
to join together as one thing.
Again,
you know what I'm saying like that there
had to be a certain peak of competition
to get us to a point where we have
created some really boundary dissolving
technology and when that point happens,
then through that very technology at as
in the Internet,
people slowly start to assimilate to
some level of understanding and
awareness that wasn't previously
achieved because there was this constant
state of of competition to try to get to
that
technological point and that's where you
run into a problem because once you
start getting to that state that you're
talking about,
and I think a lot of people are.
We add it right now.
We are right?
Yeah,
and that's when you get to that state
and suddenly you're in Egypt because
you're starting to understand about
what's going on and you're you.
You're getting this information from the
Internet showing you what other people
in other parts of the world,
how they are living.
The point is suddenly like a lot of shit
start seeming really like we've been
asked to believe a lot of stuff and
Kinda like you ask your kids to believe
a lot of stuff when they're growing up
and you do it to keep them safe.
You tell them these stories and you want
them to believe it,
but eventually your kid knows that,
you know whatever story you told him
about where the baby came from is coming
from isn't completely real and your
kid's going to start wanting to know the
truth.
And then at that age you tell your kid
the truth and it's uncomfortable or
whatever.
Even tell them the truth.
But now it's like we still have kings.
We have kings and Queens.
Their king.
There's still serious kings and you're
expecting people to keep believing this
king is any more special than anyone
else.
I.
Okay,
you want me to keep buying this thing
about the king,
about how he gets to wear the throne and
gets to have the giant fucking a mansion
that he lives in and all this property
lives in because he's a king and he's in
the bloodline is somewhat.
What are you talking about?
We're all the same man.
I got to keep playing this fucking
masquerade party with you.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
How much longer do I have to do this?
Because I'm hungry.
It's like that kind of stuff.
People are like,
okay,
so you're a president.
Oh I get it.
Okay.
So I guess I'm supposed to believe that
there's a government,
which is mostly just like 120 year old
men in a room.
I'm supposed to believe they're the ones
who know how to do everything and that
system the right way and it's like all
that stuff starts,
you know,
spreading or people like,
I don't know if I can believe the whole.
You're a cop.
I'm a person thing getting kind of hard
for me.
I mean,
I believe it because you got a billy
club and you're fucking beating my
friend in a wheelchair to death,
but I'm not sure if you really represent
the real authority of the world.
And so that kind of stuff starts
emerging in emerging as people evolve
and the authority and the world like,
fuck,
I gotta believe the game.
If you don't believe it's fucking game,
where did we don't know what to do?
What are we gonna do?
We can't just reformat everything all of
a sudden.
I.
So do you think that law enforcement
almost inhibits evolution by creating
this culture where people are getting
constantly in trouble with things?
Yeah.
Well,
you know what law enforcement,
a lot of law enforcement is,
it's delivery drivers for the prison
industrial complex.
They deliver fucking bags of gold to the
prisons.
Drop them off at the door and they
fucked.
You make so much money.
I think we need cops.
We need cops.
No question about it.
Watch that.
Richard Pryor joke about like,
well,
we need prisons.
Have you ever seen that?
So funny,
but we need.
There are aspects and elements of
society that need to be in a cage.
Yes,
absolutely.
But you know,
you don't need to be in a cage or
smoking pie.
You don't need to be in a cage for
taking your acid or taking mushrooms.
You don't need to be in a cage because
you told people that the military was
using fucking military choppers,
the gun down reporters,
and you had the balls to tell that to
the world.
That's no reason to put someone in a
cage.
So it's like it's some point as a
certain number of people realize,
okay,
this is like a kid's game.
This is a game of make believe that went
way too far and I don't feel like doing
this game of make believe anymore
because it's destroying the planet.
So you got to come up with a new game
that works,
but how are you going to convince those
60 or 120 old fucking drooling men
shitting their pants,
getting payoffs from the tobacco
companies writing bullshit laws with our
visitation.
How are you going to like convince them
like,
you know what?
What do you guys mind going home and
we're going to get some like young
people in here because they understand
more.
Do you understand the world?
But we don't understand the economic
system.
Yeah.
I'm sure some young people do lose young
people right now protesting,
listening,
saying,
I know I understand it.
Correct.
Look,
I know I.
I don't,
I don't understand it.
All I understand.
Is that video,
did you see that video I sent you today?
Did you watch that?
Fucking.
Oh,
it's a marine who is like,
you know,
he starts off and kind of dramatically
rips off his is a fucking metals and
he's like,
I'm not gonna do it anymore,
and then he just starts going into
graphic depictions of the different
innocent people he killed and he was in
Iraq and how like the marines at
completely different when there's
embedded with them a reporter than they
do and how the is now.
Now is this real?
I didn't investigate it.
I hope it's not real.
I hope it's.
It seemed very real and he talked about
how his squad commander,
whatever it's called,
said that they would,
he would congratulate them on their
first kill and he said whichever one of
you makes your first kill by stabbing
someone to death,
I'm giving you four days leave and why?
It's like that kind of shit.
Like how are you going to convince those
guys?
You know,
we should all just love each other.
Every general.
How do you stop it?
You don't,
you can't.
There's no way to stop it.
There's no way to stop it unless
somebody invents something that think
would
change the world and I'd be glad to tell
you what it is.
What is it
had genetic scientist needs to figure
out a way to put lsd and have a common
cold so that any.
So the.
So the
psychedelic experience would spread like
a virus through society.
Whoa.
And then like,
but the problem with it is you'd have to
figure out a way to design it.
So it only.
The tolerance is really huge.
Civil a person only gets at once.
That's the problem with it.
Who knows?
Maybe there's a doctor.
The problem with it is I think there's
several problems with that.
Well,
there's some other problems I suppose
really up to you to decide whether
people should be getting,
but you're trying to invent this right
now in your house right now,
right?
I'm not a chemist.
I just,
I'm just throwing it out there.
Oh my God.
He threw it out there.
You really did you fuck?
Yeah.
Way To.
Somebody might be actually thinking
about this.
I mean,
what?
So look,
here's the idea.
So.
Okay,
so let's just keep running things the
way they're running.
No,
I don't think that's going on either,
man.
I think you're.
You're not happy with the pace that
things are accelerating too.
I'm thinking you can genetically
engineer it on your own or can you?
Maybe that's what you're there for.
Maybe the guy who does that.
That really is his purpose in the
evolutionary chain.
He was supposed to step in and just see
a new leap that others weren't willing
to take and so he dragged everyone along
and he was responsible for the next
hiccup in evolution.
I just gave someone a manifesto.
How about that?
There's some fucking dude living in one
of those loft apartments where you can
drive your car up in an elevator and
he's by himself right now.
Carving is bullied of his knife.
Invest in tie dye and Hendrix now.
Okay,
well that's an interesting fucking idea
that someone could engineer a virus that
would induce a psychedelic state.
Yeah.
Or some kind of state.
I mean,
is that possible?
I have no idea.
I mean,
I,
yeah,
it seems.
It seems like if it.
It can affect your body the way some
things can.
Some codes can affect your body,
should be able to engineer something
that should affect it affects you
something that is a byproduct.
It creates a tryptamine.
When you think about a man,
when you,
when you do Mtma and the next day you,
you sort of feel like you came down
from,
from a cold,
you sort of feel like you had a cold,
so like your body was fighting something
unless
you use roll off.
Does that stuff work?
Yeah,
it does work.
It doesn't really work well.
It's not like he doesn't want to
completely bring you to a 100 percent.
I haven't,
I haven't done much.
Well I haven't done mdm made much or
molly or whatever it's called a much.
But uh,
I did once without having that and then
once with having it and it was totally
big,
big difference.
There was no hangover at all,
like the next day.
And it's just like you take it before
you do it and then after,
right before you go to roll on and roll
off,
it's a.
So you really didn't feel anything.
Anything funky?
No,
I mean I,
you're going to probably have a hangover
no matter what,
but I definitely felt that felt way
better than the last time I did.
I hate that feeling.
So not only did that stuff
once because the feeling,
it was too much though.
That feeling was too terrible.
I just felt I was in,
I was in a coffee shop the next day and
I bought a magazine with me sitting
there drinking a cup of coffee,
trying to read this magazine I couldn't
read,
couldn't focus,
I couldn't focus on the words.
I couldn't put my head into a paragraph,
couldn't do it,
and I was like,
oh,
this is terrible.
This is terrible,
terrible place for your brain to be.
And I went on stage and I felt that it
was like 80 percent.
Even though I hit all the beats,
right.
I did all my material correctly.
I felt like it was only like 80 percent,
right.
Like my brain was just not capable of
totally connecting to an,
to the material I was.
I was,
you know,
like you know how it is when you're in
the groove,
when you're onstage,
you're totally connected to the
material.
You know where the beats are,
you feel it,
you're in the jokes,
you know you're in there,
you're,
you're totally in the moment,
but sometimes not.
And then this time I just could not
force myself into it as I was saying
everything correctly,
but I couldn't quite keep up with it.
Like I was like,
this is terrible for your brain.
I've never had that feeling before.
It's like a feeling of like a,
a,
a dullness,
like a dying battery.
I felt awful.
I hate it.
It's not worth it,
but I did learn a lot when I did it,
man.
Boy,
I got a big lesson about,
about,
uh,
insecurity.
That's the thing that hit me the most is
that God,
if everybody was like,
like in some sort of a way,
the way people are during an acid trip
like,
or an MDM may trip,
it's like you would,
you never would have to worry about
fights ever again.
You would never have to worry about
people being douchey to each other.
If somehow or another,
the brain can be engineered to operate
those rpms on a regular basis.
Like as now the idea is that you take
this Mtma,
you take ecstasy,
whatever the fuck it is and it,
it makes you high for a brief moment and
then brings you down.
But what if the mind could sustain those
levels of those chemicals on a regular
basis?
I mean,
is that not possible?
Why would anyone assume we could not
evolve to that?
If we've come to this point from some
shit throwing know tree swinging little
monkey people,
if that's what we used to be and we've
come this far,
we can't take that other leap to have
the levels of chemicals in our brains
operate so that you would be like you
were on ecstasy all the time.
That would be the way to engineer a
loving culture because yeah,
I,
I did not feel stupid when I was on it,
which was very amazing that I could
think very clearly,
but I remember thinking,
wow,
how silly is our or my insecurities and
my silly imagine like in another
universe where instead of building an
atomic bomb,
Einstein,
these scientists
had come up with these theories in
physics have a way to create like a,
some kind of device that blasts pure
love and the people so that when it goes
off the city that it's in,
everyone in the city gets filled with
like as though you are on the best
ecstasy on the planet,
that level of love.
So you're at war with a country and
instead of destroying them,
you're just blasting them with love
chemicals.
So that there's no way that they can
fight.
He's going to poison a big population of
people with us are setting yourself up
as that guy.
You're Johnny appleseed for Christ.
We're good at it.
I think I actually said Johnny appleseed
incorrectly,
right?
We have we ever discussed to Johnny
appleseed,
isn't it existed then what did he do
again?
He spread out apples throughout the
midwest.
You couldn't be,
you wouldn't be the Johnny appleseed of
ecstasy,
Ecstasy.
I,
you know,
I wouldn't mind.
That's what would be a great,
great claim to fame.
But I'm not going to like,
I really obviously would never poison
people if I.
even if I had the opportunity,
but at some point,
you know,
are drastic measures have to be taken.
That's what I'm saying.
Well listen,
what you're saying,
you're saying that you're not
comfortable with the speed at which
evolution is happening.
You,
it's obvious that people are evolving,
but you're not comfortable that people
haven't reached your level yet.
So fucking solution is to engineer some
way to poison them.
Let me just dose them.
You're going to use them as Guinea pigs
and I'm for it.
I'm on time for it to you for it.
I think,
uh,
if it was 100 percent safe,
yeah,
but they would have to be all kids and
black kids blankets.
Well,
no.
Even if just kidding,
I will not be.
But what if it wasn't a hundred percent?
Say Yeah,
the 80 percent
they have to dig acid.
All right?
Some people are happy as fuck.
Living a simple life and that is their
prerogative.
This is a temporary experience.
And just because you see some great
depth into it doesn't mean you can pose
those ideals on other people that love a
simple life.
They,
there's people that are genuinely like
country music.
They like feeding animals and they're
like making fucking sweet potato pie and
that's cool.
They're called my parents.
Are Those your parents?
Try and tickling.
I'm not.
Here's the thing I'm not talking about
like literally you have.
It's never,
it's never going to happen.
I don't know.
But who could draw pictures of it?
An interest?
You have diagrams.
At what point do you
do what anonymous is doing?
At what point do you go from looking at
the world and seeing some fucked up shit
going down?
What point do you go from talking about
this shit going down to actively trying
to fight against it?
See the Warren Buffet thing?
No,
Warren Buffet just wrote some big
article on corporate taxes and why do
I have to pay so little taxes?
Why do all my super rich friends get to
bed taxes?
Any described in detail.
A bunch of crazy clauses that are in
place that allowed these guys to only
have like 17 percent taxes and
especially people that make their money
with money and you know,
there's,
there's all sorts of things that can be
factored in and because of that they
paid leave in less taxes and he's like,
this is crazy.
Like this is all engineered.
Ridiculous.
Like why are you protecting this super
rich?
It's really,
really fascinating.
It's really fascinating because he
stepped up and,
and set and it uses the terms,
like my mega rich friends,
my super rich friends,
you know,
he,
it really just kind of laid it all out.
It's fascinating.
Were you know,
when do we do something about it?
What do we do?
Because you got to do something.
At some point,
you bring it down.
Do we know who's going to build it?
Go,
you don't.
You don't have to bring it down,
but at some point you.
I just heard this thing.
It's this guy that guy's a rant on.
I don't even remember this show,
but it went viral and it's this guy
steamed up about Republican or Democrat.
It doesn't matter.
There's a system in place that is
pulling the wealth of the nation into
the overseas banking community or it was
like really intense and it went viral.
It went super viral,
but then the question is,
do we dose the irs or not?
Know at what point at what point your
bad trips,
they would have math trips.
Oh my God.
It's a vision where they just literally
stole their money and they weren't poor
and it couldn't fucking food themselves,
but when do you do?
When do you see?
Anyway,
this guy said,
we have a BOT congress.
He said,
the congress is in the pocket of
corporations.
Whether this is true or not,
I don't know,
but I did read,
if you go to a banners wikipedia page,
um,
it's felt boner,
but painter b o e h n e r,
if you go to his wikipedia page,
it talks about one of these cons.
One of the controversies around him was
that there was a big vote coming up
against big tobacco and right before the
vote happened,
he went and passed out checks from big
tobacco on the floor to all these like
senators or I don't want to passed it
out publicly and I don't know why,
what this exactly was,
but so that guys bought.
He's passing out checks from tobacco
companies in our government like that
guys bought.
It's on Wikipedia,
look it up and maybe someone can really
explain to me why I did that or what,
what,
what has happened there.
So we have what's called a Bot congress.
We have our leaders,
many of them are in the pockets of the
corporations.
Their decisions are based on the will of
the people.
Their decisions are based on what's
better for the corporations and the Mega
Rich and fucking warren buffet just went
out and talked about it.
At what point do we as a people make
that stop?
When does it happen?
Guess what?
Democracy didn't work,
didn't work.
They beat it.
They figured it out.
Of course,
they figured it out.
It's like the Rubik's cube.
You do it enough time.
Somebody's going to fucking figure out a
beat.
The Rubik's cube.
They figured it out.
The fucking founding fathers talked
about this very thing,
the possibility of this kind of thing
happening.
It happened.
Now what do we do?
What do you do?
Do you sit and drink starbucks and buy
your fucking iphone and and and fucking
play video games and get on a podcast
from time to time and wine or do you
fucking pig?
When do you do something?
That's what I want to know.
When do people act like and that's why
I'm so fascinated with fucking anonymous
right now because they're acting.
They're,
no matter what people said,
oh,
they're just a bunch of 14 year olds at
the basement of their Bob's house.
I don't think so.
They just fucking did it.
They shut down train stations.
They're shutting shit down there.
Like black.
Yeah.
One one step away is Obama is going to
go on television going,
okay,
just so you know,
we're now considering these guys
terrorists.
That's all it's going to happen.
And then these 14 year olds that are in
basements who are thinking they're doing
a good job,
are now going,
okay,
now we're going to get in prison for 60
years and now federal crime.
Okay.
No,
I'm not worth them going back to work
thing,
but that's all that stuff all they need
to do to stop,
but for the rest of the history,
okay,
for the rest of history,
if every member of whatever this
mysterious weird group is,
gets arrested tomorrow for the rest of
time,
they still will exist as an
organization.
That was one of the first emergent,
a revolutionary organizations in the
technological age and to me that is
amazing.
Oh,
it's super amazing and I,
I completely support them,
but that they're just better watch out
because I think that's coming.
I think they're doing it.
They're going to be considered
terrorists.
The second course,
I mean,
our country considers anything that goes
against their ideals,
terrorism to the point where it's
obvious that certain people aren't there
in surgeons.
Those are insurgents.
What the fuck's an insurgent?
Yeah.
Those are people who don't want you
invading their country.
They're not insurgents.
You're gonna.
Call them an insurgent.
Do you know how many fucking kids?
And uh,
Afghanistan died from a drone attacks.
They just released it like 168 kids.
Dad from drone attacks.
A lot of insurgents apparently.
Don't understand why you got to blow up
toddlers.
So the question is when,
when,
when did people choose?
I can imagine if you were living over
there,
if that's your role,
the dice.
You're a fucking mountain goat herder in
Afghanistan and you literally are under
the power of various warlords.
No one city in the entire country cobble
everything else.
Assist warlords,
warlords,
dude or Lord,
you know,
you know how they get the information
from the warlords?
They give him Viagra.
That's how they find out where the
Taliban is.
They give him Viagra.
That's the number one move.
July.
Hopefully you didn't learn that on
cinemax after.
Now.
Dude,
I read that online.
I read it online.
That's amazing.
Authenticated.
It was on a major website.
I don't remember what.
So what we know,
but it totally makes sense.
These old dudes,
they can't fucking anymore and they have
all these.
They all have all these hoes like when
you're aboard,
Lord,
you don't have one wife.
You've got to bang a wives.
You got a gang of wives,
right?
He's like,
sixties.
Dick doesn't work anymore and he's got
these 20 bitches.
He's trying to hold down.
It's hard.
Yeah.
It's not like you can order Viagra when
you live in a fucking deadly valley.
Like they even knew about it.
Right?
I bet the first time they ever dropped
it and they're like,
get the fuck outta here.
Wow.
I killed it.
Makes your Dick hard.
Like what color geniuses are out there?
Well,
I'm herding goats on a mountain
somewhere.
It's fucked up that we can use those
drones and other countries that we're
not even supposed to be at war with
Pakistan.
Just sneak a drone over there and shoot
some shit.
All right,
we're going to leave now with hell fire
missiles.
That's the craziest thing they named
them.
They don't have the name like h,
two,
five,
six,
no.
Hell fire.
Hellfire missiles fired.
Actually.
Then maybe they do.
Maybe the hellfires that nickname.
Mad,
angry,
efficient autos to follow up.
It's so creepy,
man.
If you think about that stuff too much
god,
especially if you man,
if you eat mushrooms and your brain
decides to start thinking about the
Taliban.
Oh God,
that's the worst.
You just.
I've rolled against the wall of my
fucking apartment,
clutching my head with visions of
bearded strangers,
strapping suicide bombs to their bodies
and wandering into the streets to blow
up other people.
When you really consider that this
happens at this very second,
right now,
there's two things happening.
There's a guy at fucking Halliburton
who's screwing the top on a hell fire
missile that no doubt will land in some
playground in Afghanistan and a center
eight some toddlers,
and he's like,
ah,
almost off work
these.
I got a screw on.
There's that guy and then there's some
guy in the Middle East right now
strapping a fucking belt around his
waist and he's got a little time or a
phone and he's buttoning everything up
and he knows that any second,
like in the next hour or two,
he's going to be hamburger meat all over
some fucking cafe or hotel.
That's so weird.
We live in.
These are the two insane people and I
frankly think one's a lot crazier than
the other and it ain't the fucking guy
with a bomb belt.
It's the fucking Weirdos,
like just screw in the top side.
Ms Dot wonder where these are going to
go.
Keep pushing these bombs.
Here's another box of Gloucester.
Oops.
Ah,
Shit.
I wonder why it malfunctioned like that.
Perhaps we should analyze the four.
13 chip a.
You just killed toddlers.
Oh yeah,
of course.
But I wonder what it.
What it is.
Maybe the battery malfunctioned
batteries malfunctioning in your heart.
Murderers.
That's the thing.
It's like,
why are we doing this?
The fuck's going on that poppy field
thing on internet where you're talking
about
the soldiers standing in the poppy
fields,
yet another thing not to listen to when
you're fucking begged,
that'll send you a hireling into a
paranoid episode quicker than seeing
your grandmother.
That has never been a more clear
indication that they're in on it than
soldiers guarding poppy fields.
And for me,
he just to.
You got it.
At a certain point in time,
you got to go,
wait what?
They had uriel,
Geraldo Rivera,
and he was interviewing one of the
soldiers.
There was like,
yeah,
well we don't like it,
but we have to guard the fields.
Uh,
in order to get information for these
people,
we have to let them live their way of
life.
Like,
what are you talking about,
son?
Are you really telling me you're letting
people grow heroin?
And you guys are guarding it.
But that's it.
That's all.
You don't have any financial stake in
it.
You know,
we're,
we're taking American lives and they're
over there with machine guns,
gardening poppy fields.
For who?
By who?
Against who?
Excuse me,
what the fuck is going on?
We don't know.
Where's the money going?
When you're,
you're,
someone's getting paid.
You fuck.
You don't have soldiers one or two
fields.
Unless there's some money being
exchanged.
Hands,
period.
That's expensive to feed us.
Why the fuck would they put the
resources of those soldiers?
Why would they put them to use in that
area like that?
You know what that makes me think
though,
man.
How fucking cool would it be to have
your own army?
Wouldn't that be awesome to have like
200,
like an army?
There's people that know what it's like
to have an army to have like a.
are you with having an army?
Well,
you know what,
what,
what happened with Blackwater,
right?
Do you know what happened with now?
Supposedly this is all supposedly the
uh,
they just got some giant crazy contract
with the United Arab Emirates and
they're gonna,
you know,
I think it's like an Abu Dhabi,
maybe I not.
They're starting like a private
military.
You know,
he's putting together some crazy
mercenary group to shut down uprisings
and make sure that no,
no,
nobody shit happens and they'll lose all
their money.
I heard of.
I actually heard about this.
Isn't it called Cobra?
I don't know.
I don't know if it's true.
It's true.
Called Cobra.
Cobra.
I made that up as well.
This guy
who was the,
um,
the guy that was the head of Blackwater
is apparently got some huge deal to go
over there.
So I read a line that would make sense,
man.
If I was some fucking dude in the Middle
East like that.
Oh,
I was a king.
I was like,
I need to protect this shit.
I don't have to hire them.
And once you get to that position,
we ain't going to let that go.
No one's letting that go.
Why would you let that go?
I'm the king to shut the fuck up.
I got a new army where we got shit a
lock down.
Like you're going to resist any form of
the simulation.
I don't
care what you song.
Google a palace.
I got to keep up.
What would it be like to be a king and
have an acid trip?
Really deep acid trip.
That's great.
I think so,
yeah.
Like having a fucking Harem tripping on
acid and knowing you had access to a
Harem and things got weird.
Don't you think you would freak out
thinking about all the people that hated
you and all the people that wanted you
dead,
all the people that wanted your throne.
Sure.
You just get the joke to dance
for you and you'll forget about it.
I mean just being living in any sort of
a place where there's one person that is
thought to be the king,
the king king,
King of Jordan and the King of Egypt,
the king and the queen of.
That's got to be a terrifying position
to be the king.
Yeah.
You must be totally paranoid all the
time.
Yeah,
of course.
I mean,
look at that.
Look at President Obama has got to ride
and he's got to ride into kind of
bulletproof fucking hearst thing course
also because he's black.
Let's be honest.
That's the real reason.
The real reason.
That's a big reason why people try to
kill Ronald Reagan.
Of course.
You know,
people would think someone there wasn't
there some sort of a thwarted attempt
against,
um,
it was something about George w dot,
but they got it like way before anything
happened.
It was a grenade I think were trying to
elaborate on stage.
Either way.
There's,
I mean there's,
there's always,
there's always one crazy faction of
society that wants this,
this president dead or the United States
president did for whatever reason.
But I always feel like with Obama,
like the shit that I hear online and the
things that I've read,
it's like the racism.
It's pretty obvious,
man.
There's a lot of people don't just not
like him as a person.
They don't like him because he's black.
Oh,
funny.
Talk about it pretty openly and calm a
monkey and calm.
Like it's like,
it's really,
really fucking fascinating.
Like the,
the level of disrespect.
You know,
the idea.
You just imagine right now the way
you're going to feel the day after
Michele Bachmann gets elected,
if she kinda liked to imagine how you
going to feel.
I'm going to feel,
I'm going to feel how much money does it
cost me every year to live in Vancouver
and I called my accountant and I'm going
to say,
all right,
now,
tell me what I would have to do.
I'd have to pay taxes in both places.
Okay.
I can do that though and I can live
there and I keep.
I can still be United States Senate
said,
let's fucking do it.
I would just do it.
I just moved the fuck up there is the
way racist felt when Obama got elected.
Of course that's been rocking sense of
like horror that some people had,
not because of his views,
not getting his ideas,
but because he's black.
They were like,
oh my fucking God.
This is it.
Charlie over sudden.
Amazing.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
So yeah man,
it's completely out there.
And then you add onto that the fact that
he fucking didn't exactly hit a home run
to put it lightly duty.
He stepped up to plate and got hit with
a meteor shower.
I mean,
I don't think any president had any
chance of making any of this.
Look good.
There was a gigantic scheme going on.
It collapsed and created this vortex of
suck and unemployment and home
foreclosures and anybody stepping into
that vortex would have been sucked into
its momentum.
Yeah,
ducks that while he was in that fucking
vortex,
he like started
saying that people could start rating
medicinal marijuana.
Dispensary is again under him.
They started doing that.
Did they say that they rated them
because they violated both state and
federal law?
Do you know because that was one of the
claims that Obama says.
He never said that he would stop rating
medical marijuana clinics.
I think the,
the,
the language they used was they were
going to stop unless they were violating
both state and federal law.
So if someone was selling marijuana,
you automatically violating federal law,
but are you staying within the state
guidelines?
If so,
then we're going to leave you alone,
but if not,
then we're gonna go after you and that's
what they did.
That's what he said.
Because I heard there was a new thing
that's.
I don't know.
I heard I heard that too,
but I didn't investigate it enough to be
talking about it,
but very hard for me to hate our country
so much.
Duncan.
No,
I love it,
but let me be clear about this.
I don't think we're happy.
I'm not happy until there's full
legalization and here's the problem with
this idea of medical is that I believe,
at least in my,
the way I understand it,
that it can be interpreted,
that the only way you're supposed to be
running one of these collectives and
dispensary's is you're not supposed to
be making any profit.
I believe they're supposed to be not a
nonprofit sort of a business,
but obviously these people are making a
fuck load of money,
so it's a very tricky sort of a gray
area that's going on right now,
so I'm not,
I'm not even happy with just the medical
distinction.
It's silliness.
It's 2011.
Any argument about giving any,
any inches or any.
Just anything at all in that direction.
Like,
okay,
well maybe we should make it illegal.
If you're not,
stop it.
It's a fucking plant.
All right.
You can't.
You can't make it illegal.
It's a fucking plant.
It grows in the ground.
You can't say it's no good if it's not.
It's not a poison.
How come there's all these plants that
grow strychnine?
They make strict none.
They don't.
You can buy them.
You could sell Salvia at target and I
would think that Salvia is way more
dangerous for kids.
Salvia plants the nursery.
Go check.
That's the same type of Salvia.
I don't know,
but I do know that they sell the San
Pedro Cactus at like Home Depot San
Pedro.
Cactus is how you get Mescalin.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's where pod comes from.
You can take that fucking cactus and you
can,
if you know how to do it.
There's a whole,
there's a bunch of,
you know,
like,
uh,
forums that will show you how to go
through step by step process online.
Yeah,
man,
it's fucked up.
Fucking.
It's ridiculous.
It's not just fucked up.
It's like that.
If there's a,
there's a one thing that has to happen,
the first thing that's going to happen.
And people don't put as much stock into
this idea because it seems like a silly
request,
but if you could fix anything about the
world,
what would you do?
I'd make psychedelics regularly
available and legal and have people and
devote energy and money to studying them
and
distributing them correctly and get
people who are showmen to take people in
authentic trips,
people who have navigated these worlds.
And then when the people come back and
they need like help with this
reprogramming.
You sit down with them.
You have groups of people that have also
had the experience to sit down with
them.
Discuss what about it?
Did it make you think about yourself?
Was that it?
Was there anything that like glaringly
obvious you needed to change?
And then you know,
the person would say,
yeah,
we'll,
there's this fucking thing that freaks
me out.
I'm kind of a cheap fuck.
And I think we need to deal with that.
Right?
I mean,
you're kind of selfish.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I don't know what it is.
I just like,
it's fucking,
it's a force of habit and if you're,
if you have any weird sort of a
personality tick like that and you do
any psychedelic,
even eat pot,
just eat,
eat a cookie,
Matt.
That's the first thing that's going to
hit you.
You're going to think about being a
creepy person.
Think about your creepy behavior.
You know,
and if,
if there's ever a way to reengineer
society,
it's to shock people out of their
current pattern of behavior that they
find almost unavoidable.
The same patterns that caused people to
overeat or chronic masturbation.
The we have to figure out a way to blast
people out of those shock you out of the
pattern.
Show you yourself from an angle or
perspective that's not available without
the psychedelic,
than bring you back and give you
something to think about.
You know,
it's like these little trips,
these little blasts,
the just little bursts of evolution.
It's society.
You see yourself,
you see how you can fit.
You see,
Nice,
you see positive,
good.
I'll see you in a couple months and just
keep doing that.
And every couple months people go in and
get blasted,
talk to people,
people,
talk them through situations and tell
them about ego.
And then it's all a trick and it's just
temporary anyway,
men,
the most,
the best feeling you'll ever get is to
be really cool to as many people as you
can,
the best feeling you'll ever get.
It's just to be nice to as many people
as you can.
Be friendly to them,
shake their hand,
hug them if you can,
and just be someone that other people
enjoy to be around.
When you do that,
you create positive energy.
You create love.
You create this,
this,
this burst comes from you and you
attracted and you bring it into your
seeing a couple of months and then the
guy goes back every couple of months,
did one trip after another and a year
later you gotta.
You can't even recognize this guy.
A year later,
this guy is fucking eating organic food
and drinking coconut water and go into
cross fit and reading about the Bhagavad
Gita and he become a different human
being.
You become a human being.
That's,
that's actualized.
That's a good word.
It's a good word.
You know,
that is possible.
You can evolve without drugs.
You can evolve just with hard work and
focus and attention in meditation or you
can just take the drugs and get there
way quicker.
It's up to you man.
Go crazy.
And combined it two,
you know,
you don't.
It's not like we can only do one or the
other.
Actually I found the combination of the
two
is amazing.
Getting really high and chanting is such
a perfect synergy.
It's the,
it's so fun to do,
but I mean getting high,
doing anything,
it's pretty
to be the most amazing is getting high
and doing yoga.
Dude,
I love to get super big.
I'll get begged and hotel rooms and I'll
do yoga.
I got like some,
a few dvds and I got one thing that I've
downloaded that I can watch on my laptop
doomed get which is bullitt streaked.
So you're just in tune with every fiber
of your muscles and you're holding these
poses and I'm reading from this book
that as this fucking black and white
photo of this Indian dude doing it from
1934 and he's doing these crazy ass
fucking poses and I'm holding him in his
hotel room and then after I'm done,
man,
it's like it takes the high and brings
it to this completely new room.
It's super clean and it's like you sit
here in this new room and just this is
just relax a little until the yoga wears
off.
Then you can go right back in.
It's like it puts you in some crazy new
high room or you're like,
I can see things so well right now.
It's like my body's in balance.
My mind is imbalanced.
I can see things so clearly.
Troubling.
Decision seemed so obvious.
I would love to see both of your
favorite thing to do high together at
the same time,
like you chanting and you're doing yoga
in the same room.
I think that you guys should do that
sometime.
It'd be very well,
but we can put that online and dudes.
Right.
Beat off to fucking God.
Bear 69 cock beat officer thing.
Cool.
I love your asshole
Henry.
Awesome.
Can I ask you something?
Brian started talking about it.
So what'd you think of planet of Apes?
Listen Bro.
Oh,
here we go.
I got
way more chimping me than the average
person.
So you put me in movie with chimps.
Start fucking shit up.
I get very excited.
All right.
I thought the CGI was the shit I thought
for a movie for like what?
I like to go to the movies to say I want
to see some fun shit.
I like comic book movies.
I like,
you know,
like x men was the latest Eczema and I
really liked that one a lot.
I liked that kind of shit.
I like ridiculous movies.
First Class.
I just liked that one.
I liked shit.
That's like,
I like stuff that's fun,
you know,
I wanna I want to just get into it.
And to me this movie was so.
First of all the special effects were
fucking insane.
So close to perfect,
swell.
Close to seeming like real chimps.
Can I say something?
Yeah,
here we go.
I don't want to see it.
You haven't seen it?
No,
I've seen it,
but I don't want to see chimp cock.
But none of those chimps that genitals.
It's true from PG.
Thirteen.
Well,
it's not that they didn't have genitals,
they just never showed you an angle
where you could the deck.
Here's the thing was just clever
photography.
Everything.
Everything that you've just described
about the movie.
I agree with the CGI was fucking cool
and there were some really cool moments,
but what bothered me about the movie or
really bothered me about the movie,
um,
was the penis and what made it,
what made it kind of what made me really
start eating it a halfway through and
get embarrassed by it and just think,
oh,
I'll never go see a fucking movie again
in my life.
Yeah.
I got so pissed because I saw at the
beginning fucking News Corp and I was
like,
oh,
here we go.
How did fucking Rupert Murdoch fuck this
up?
How did he fuck it up?
These chimps,
these fucking chimps who have been
tortured in laboratories who I've,
I told you by the time I almost got
killed by a chimpanzee already,
right?
I told you that story.
When was this?
I didn't tell you that story.
Even if you did tell him to tell me
again.
I'm sure a lot of people never heard of
it.
Tell me.
So I,
for this pilot I did for comedy central,
we had a chimpanzee as one of the gags
where I was playing chess with a
chimpanzee and the chimpanzee beat me at
a move.
And so,
so I go,
I'm smarter than me.
She's a stupid quick gag,
like a computer hooked up to the champ
and like the,
it says checkmate,
the commuters that.
Right.
So I was really excited about this day
and my friend,
uh,
Tom Janice,
who was the co creator of the show and
directed it was,
um,
he,
uh,
he kept telling me,
Dunkin,
is that you?
Do you think there's any way we could do
this without a chimp or do you really
want to have a chimpanzee?
Because I've worked with chimpanzees
before and they're really hard to
control on set and they're dangerous and
I'm like,
no,
I want to work with a chimp man.
I'm not going to say no to Oregon with a
chimp and they're not dangerous and
they're going to sense that I'm a nice
guy and the chimpanzee is going to know
I'm okay and it's going to be fine.
I was looking forward to this for days
because I've always wanted to fucking
hold a chimpanzee.
So a fucking.
The chimp gets here,
you know that.
I know the chimps there cause it's
punching.
The hardwood floor is hard as it can,
as it's coming down through to where
we're shooting.
It's just punching the floor,
punching the floor,
Bang,
Bang.
This fucking thing.
It looks like if you took a toddler and
just blasted it with steroids,
it's like imagine the most muscular
toddler with the worst case of add on
the planet.
That's a chimpanzee.
And so right before we started shooting,
the guy says,
okay,
just so you guys know this,
a very friendly monkey.
I'm cold monkey or I'm sorry,
chimp,
I'm,
I've,
I'm going to get trainers sucks too
much.
I'm trying to determine is there a
Harvard for chimp trainers?
You just fucking get a chimp.
If you say you're a trainer,
you can rent the thing out.
Don't you have to be a problem at all?
Just or something.
I don't know.
Okay.
So this fucking monkey.
So he's like,
just,
you know,
the chimpanzees,
the most strongest person in the room if
he comes up to you,
he just wants to say hi.
He's very friendly,
just don't make any quick movements.
And so suddenly this chimp is sitting in
front of me and it goes from being like,
oh,
this is going to be cute to being like,
this is no different than being with a
tiger.
This thing is fucking strong.
It seems kind of focused in core right
now.
But it was being a little weird earlier.
How big was it?
Uh,
I,
I don't,
I don't know the weight of the thing.
It was probably like a little higher
than my waist,
like with a,
with a chimp crouch happening.
So you say maybe 70 pounds,
80 pounds?
Um,
I'd say like a,
probably 80 pounds or something.
I don't know.
So it's not a baby?
No,
it's a,
it's a middle aged little guy wearing
blue jeans.
I think it's more than 100.
I don't.
I don't know.
It wasn't.
No,
I could.
I don't know.
I could've picked it up.
Muscular Shit.
Right.
So the real muscular.
So we're,
we're starting to do the scene.
Chimps.
Got to move a piece,
by the way,
for animal rights people out there.
I will never,
ever,
ever use a chimpanzee again in anything
that I ever do.
I don't advocate it.
It's cruel.
It's a horrible thing.
It's fucked up.
These creatures belong and habitats are
in the wild.
They do not belong on a movie set.
They're very cool,
very cool creatures.
But that's a.
it's a terrible thing.
I agree.
Totally.
I'm fucking sitting there and the
basically in like two seconds,
the chimp went from being calm and kind
of focused to screaming at the top of
its lungs and shooting past me.
It may be 20 miles per hour,
like like there's no way I could have
reacted if it wanted to pounce on me.
I couldn't have blocked it.
It was just this bang,
like a whitening bullet shoots by me and
runs to the top of this divider.
So now it's pulling like a King Kong.
It's like it's screaming at all of us
and I'm like,
fuck.
I'm feeling the worst sense of guilt and
fear.
Anyway,
we'll get it back down.
Holy Shit.
We get it back down.
Everything's fine again.
It's like nothing happened.
I didn't just freak out and just have
it.
It's cool.
Gets off.
It's like,
Whoa,
whoa.
Hold on.
This thing freaked out.
And you went back to work with it again.
Yes.
Oh my God.
I went back to work,
went back to work to get the shot.
Man.
It's low budget and fuck it man.
Let's go for it.
So what if I lose my hockey?
And I was terrified.
It was a bad decision in retrospect to
them in the moment.
I decided to do it.
So things in front of me again and it's
calmed down and it's kind of cool.
Now I look over,
the trainer is sweating like,
you know,
nervous sweat,
like nervous,
nervous sweat.
And I swear I hear the guy who's with
him whisper to him.
Should we go ahead relationship?
Not yet.
He yells,
yells at the guy.
So I'm thinking like,
did he just suggest that they dart the
big dark the chimp or something?
Like they calm it down like something's
not right with the chimp right now.
So anyway,
thing goes for me again,
not for me,
but shoots out of the chair again.
The guy tackles it.
Football tackles the chimp,
right?
Football tackles this poor fucking
creature.
The guy hits his head on a chair,
he hits his nose on a chair from
tackling the champ.
The chimp didn't,
uh,
the chimp didn't bite him,
but he,
he,
he hit his nose.
I saw him do it.
So because he tackled the champ,
why do you tackle the chimp?
He saw something in the chimps eyes that
made him think,
I got to tackle this chimp.
So he tackles the chimp.
He stands up every,
I look around,
the crew is like white faced.
I'm sitting here frozen in terror.
I look over the chimp is projectile
vomiting bananas because that's what
they do and they get anxious and the was
like,
guys,
we can go on.
Everything's fine.
Blood running down his face from where
he slammed into the chair,
just blood just gushing down the guy's
face.
And uh,
no.
I'm like,
no,
you know what?
I think we got it.
Let's,
let's call us.
Let's call this a day.
And that,
that happened man.
Those fucking things are fast and deadly
and dangerous and fucking kind of half
insane because they're out of their
environment.
So when I went to see planet of apes and
the first time one of those chimps went
to kill someone and the chimps like,
no,
you know,
we mustn't kill.
Let's let these humans live.
I'm like,
fuck that chimps.
If they were superintelligent they'd be
ripping people to like fucking Turkey on
Thanksgiving.
That's what annoyed me about it should
have been brutal.
It was more real that you wanted to be
more realistic to see monkeys like
written,
not just by the way,
like all these monkeys seem really good
at jumping through a office glass.
If they.
If they weren't,
it would be the most boring movie ever.
If they're all hitting the glass and
falling back,
grabbing the workers in the office and
slamming their bodies into the glass,
like bean bags,
it's splitting them like fucking so you
didn't have fun with the movie at all.
You couldn't look at it.
I did think that some of that jump into
the glass shit was ridiculous,
but I was willing to let it go because
it was a fun movie.
Yeah,
that's what I would think.
So me.
It was just so fun.
Bad ass moving.
Listen,
there is that part of my brains here
that's like,
well,
this is fucking cool,
but I'm not discounting what you're
saying.
I completely agree with you.
If they went full chimpanzee,
what a.
What a champ would really be lucky.
As intelligent.
Who would be a horror film?
A horror film of epic proportions with
the chimps would storm the town and just
kill all the people.
Exactly.
Utilize them.
That's really what would happen.
I saw this really cool picture on this
website.
I go to call this information and that
sounds like a real credible source.
It's a great website,
man.
They put up here the invitation dot.
What did you.
Where'd you get the article?
Oh,
it was on disinformation.com.
That sounds like you immediately just
fall into one of those people that are
constantly searching for the truth
behind the lies.
It's not a conspiracy side.
It's more like it's a good site.
I'm just.
I'm just saying like I've go to her it
all the time.
I'm just saying that if that's one of
those like hot buttons like
disinformation dot Com Info.
It's like a website cause we lie to you.
They have the book to the people that
have.
You're being lied to.
Is that the people that produce that
book right in and the whole series of
those books,
which are great.
Fantastic.
By the way,
books you.
You realize.
How many times do you have been lied to?
All throughout history and it's like,
Whoa,
what the hell about that too?
Everything,
but there's a picture on this site,
have a painting.
Someone did a planet of the apes and
it's these apes with guns standing in
front of a pile of dead human bodies
like their hunters posing with like
things that they've killed.
Now.
That's cool when I see that because then
they're really playing that like we flip
the script.
Here's what we years that planet of the
apes by showing monkeys behaving like
humans do.
It was a cool creative way to amplify
the cruelty and humanity and brutality
of humans.
That was an important aspect of it is
the monkeys were supposed to be a cruel
to things that they didn't think were
smart,
so the fact that these are distant
ancestors started off as like what
appears to be.
It seems like while that chimp was
getting educated,
he got a nice heavy dose of like some
form of like,
this is no spoilers by the way.
Right?
You're not going to drop some spoilers
on us because I haven't seen it yet.
It's planted the fucking names.
If you don't know what's about talking
monkeys.
Yeah.
It's a little bit of a spoiler.
Sorry.
Look,
I see what you're saying.
I think.
I don't think that.
Oh,
come on,
man.
That movie.
It was fun for me.
I enjoy the shit out of it,
but you could make a movie where it
would be all of the scenes from King
Kong and from the hulk,
whether they were just smashing
everything and I would watch that movie.
You'd be like 40 minutes.
I would pay $20 to go see just a video
of the whole fucking shit up for 20
minutes and fucking shit up.
Yeah.
That's so fun.
The people screaming when he's stepping
on them.
The last King Kong.
That's awesome.
I just love the idea of the special
effects.
Did you like Godzilla as much?
Yeah.
I liked that when I was a kid.
You know?
What were those movies back then were so
stupid.
It's like you,
you,
we all agreed that we're stupid.
We didn't think that was like a real
monster.
There was no doubt.
That was not a real monster,
but we were willing to go along with it
because it was kind of fun.
There was no doubt the water would not
move that way if it was really the ocean
that's a goddamn bathtub,
there's no doubt,
but we were willing to accept it because
it was kind of cool movie.
What?
What's fun for me now is I just love
watching these artificially created
creatures that have been rendered on a
computer and people are interacting with
them.
That to me,
like the King Kong scene,
when when King Kong falls down in the
newest king county falls down in between
these two into a,
like a big crater or something like
that.
It's a big canyon.
Anyway,
he falls down to this big crack and
there's all these vines and shit and
he's duking it out with trx is all along
the way.
Wally's like juggling this chick and
while you're watching it's like,
God damn,
this is a motion picture piece of art.
This is a masterpiece.
What they've done.
This really does look like a giant
gorilla fighting off t rexes that's
fucking bad ass and it's really.
It really does look like kids
interacting with trees.
It really does.
It's amazing when the fucking gorilla
gets to the ground,
starts duking it out with them and it's
like,
that really looks like a really.
This is incredible.
Blown away by that shit blown away
because I can't I when you hear about
like computer languages,
like I've watched John Carmax do this,
this speech about the new technology in
their game rage and like all the
different cool tweaks and different
things that they've done with it.
Remember when we went there,
when we were in Dallas,
we got a chance to go.
It's software.
They let us go walk around the studio
and look at the game before it was ever
made.
Dude,
you will listen to him talk and it's
like my brain is so far removed from any
of this knowledge.
I his what he's discussing with how they
created video game moves,
how they,
how they have changed the way the game
interacts with people and I know he's
doing this with ones and zeros or
numbers on white paper.
It's so far.
He's my.
He might as well be an alien.
He might as well be a different species.
They May.
Somebody was just telling me that
programmers brain start working
differently because they're constantly
thinking and coding language and it
creates this difference in the way their
brains work,
which I didn't really understand,
but that totally makes sense.
Yeah.
When I just want.
I use photoshop and I think like
somebody built this,
like somebody figured out how to do
this,
that,
that is insane to me.
It's who are these people?
It's like we're giving academy awards
and like huge awards and accolades to
like symmetrical people who are really
good at like reciting lines in a
specific way.
How come like the famous people in our
society aren't these super geniuses who
are building phones?
Why don't we have like awards for people
who make the crazy shit that makes our
life so much better?
It's really weird,
Jonny Lynn's fit flair.
It is very weird.
Well,
let's.
Because our society is sort of developed
and evolved without much planning.
It's sort of just happened and as we are
this weird combination of evolving being
an animal with needs and instincts,
there's a lot of variables that don't
get it accounted for as it'd behavior
forms into patterns and you know,
and cultures evolve around giant masses
of land that it doesn't get planned out.
But I always feel just like a field with
any pattern that is established in
nature.
I always feel that the most fucked up
human behavior,
all of it.
The whole pile of it all has got to all
be natural.
That's all almost unavoidable.
That this is just what the human being
does and as we are older and have much
less responsibility than most people,
you know,
30 years ago,
or rather a 300 years ago,
our age were literally dying,
you know,
500 years ago.
How long,
how long do people live in,
you know,
and it was,
it was,
it was normal.
It was normal a thousand years ago.
Oh No,
I looked at that.
I think it's like 32 years.
If you can look up the lifespan of
people,
it's like a thousand years ago.
It's like 18 hundreds.
It's almost to me like we're not
supposed to get old enough to see the
hustle.
Right?
It's almost like we're.
We're designed to die off right?
When we start going,
what?
Wait a minute,
what the fuck are we doing?
Hey,
hey,
hey.
Everybody settled down.
What do we.
What exactly are we doing here?
But that's when we were supposed to
heart failure.
That's what,
that's what it should supposed to quit.
But we're,
we're alive so much longer now because
of nutrition and medicine and people are
just,
they're more,
they're more conscious.
A first person like yourself has more
free time as well and more free time to
contemplate,
and you're in a nonconformist occupation
where you're not constantly pressured
every day to thinking along certain
lines because as a real issue with the
American worker,
you think you're given eight hours a
day,
but you're not given eight hours a day.
You're given eight hours a day,
plus your behavior outside of work can't
get much too crazy in comparison to your
behavior inside of work or it's gonna
Affect your performance at work.
You can't be partying too much and
coming into work hung over,
so the whole thing must be regulated so
everybody has to stay in La.
You can get crazy and say sexist jokes
around female coworkers or you'll go to
jail.
All right,
you'll be arrested.
You.
You'll lose money because of sexual
harassment.
You know if you fire her,
you,
you're going to get sued and these are
all that.
This is all like an impossible thing to
avoid.
If you're not a normal person working a
normal job,
it's impossible for you to avoid your
behavior being altered just so that you
can work
well.
Yeah,
you're you heirs the game.
If people forgot they were playing.
It's called Western society and most
people,
the way they play that game is they have
to.
There's different roles they take.
There's the worker in the boss,
there's the executive as the president
police officers,
and it's all a game.
When you go and buy,
buy a starbucks.
I learned this.
There's a really cool meditative
technique you can do that's part of this
stuff,
this guy gurdjieff talks about,
but it's basically shows you how you're
essentially just a series of automatic
functions throughout the day.
You're not even there,
but at what you do is when you go to buy
something,
just be aware of the way you buy
something.
Watch the way your hand gets your
wallet.
Watch the way the money or the card
comes out.
Watch the way you swipe the card,
watch the way you talk to the person and
watch the way the person talks to you
and what you'll see happening is
something you've been doing for years
and years and years and years and years
and years,
over and over and over again to buying
shit because you live in America and
that's how he fucking survive.
It's buying shit at the cash register.
It's a just a great way to see how when
you do that,
your body goes into this automated
function.
Get the wall,
pull the card,
say thanks in a weird way.
Look at the person.
If you look at the person you're seeing
an Automaton,
you're seeing a person who has put their
consciousness on the shelf,
why they like all day long process
people's cards,
process people cards.
So what you're seeing is two machines
having this interaction and it's really
fucking a great exercise to do because
what you're seeing is a game that you've
been playing so long you've forgotten
you've.
You're playing that game.
You learned out a bit pot by shit at a
cash register.
There was a time when you'd never bought
something at the cash register when you
were a kid and then your parents taught
you how to do it.
You learned how to exchange money for
goods and that crystallized,
do this ritual that you don't even know
as a ritual.
It's just this automatic thing,
so this fucking game of Western society.
It invites people to become automatons
to get through the day when you're like,
I used to wash dishes at applebee's and
I can remember like the way that you
would get through the day of washing
dishes is you just go into this
automatic trans.
She's a trans,
spray the dish,
but in thing wash,
scrub up,
put it in anything.
It's just an automatic trance.
You're there,
but you're not really there.
You're just in a trance and you do it as
an escape from the monotony and dullness
of the job.
Well,
it should be one person is cleaning
their own plate.
That's what it should be,
right?
It shouldn't be.
There's a giant stack of plates in
someone's job.
It is to clean those things because
that's when things start to suck.
That's when jobs start to suck,
when you're doing all this shit for
money that no one wants to do.
There's a big difference between that
kind of a job and the kind of a job
where you actually have a career and do
things you enjoy like you and you get
paid to be a professional comedian.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's A.
I mean,
it's not even,
it shouldn't even be classified as a
job.
Yeah.
It doesn't feel like it.
And call it a career if you want to get
pretentious,
but you know,
it's your thing.
The career thing is a horrible word,
man.
It's a weird word because it makes you
feel like,
you know,
I'm fucking serious grindstone.
But it's the,
it's comes the derivation of the word is
a track.
Horses ran on really circle.
You'd never get anywhere.
You just run into fucking circle.
That's what a career is.
I'm working on my career.
Like the,
the,
the um,
yeah.
I think that I feel very lucky.
I feel incredibly lucky.
And also I feel like,
uh,
always on the precipice of absolute
disaster.
There's something really quite a,
a peaceful about having a regular
paycheck.
Man,
there's something really nice about
that.
That's fucking cool to now.
Every two weeks you're getting a
paycheck.
That's bad ass,
so that life of working a job and having
a regular job,
it is.
There's sweetness to it,
man,
and it facilitates having babies and it
facilitates a lot of aspects of life
that I think are quite pleasurable on a
really high level,
so I totally get it.
It's just a,
you know,
is there a way that this process that
we're all engaged in this gigantic game
that we're all in this crazy dance of
Western civilization that we're all
engaged in.
Is there a way that we can take it up a
level?
Is there a way we can make it a little
more aware of itself?
A little more cognizant of itself,
a little less embedded in superstition,
and
again,
I've got to go to what I said before is
that I think that things are evolving.
You just are not happy with the pace.
I think that we live in such a tiny
frame as tiny window of time and the
amount of progress that we're looking at
just from a thousand years to now is
monumental 2000 years to now and human
behavior,
knowledge and access to information off
the charts,
how much it's progress and we're just
caught in the middle of it and it's key.
It's not going to stop with with the
Internet and with the the access to
information that's available now and the
ability to communicate now.
Truth is getting through more often than
not.
Truth is piling on.
There's a lot of bullshit out there
still,
but it's way easier to cut the bullshit
off with the Internet.
It's evolving.
It's just not evolving up to your speed,
the what you would like to see,
but just look at the way people think,
act and behave now as composed as
compared to the way they did turn truck.
There's no question and that's not even
a blink of an eye.
Not even a blink of an eye.
It's unquestionably moving in a certain
direction and yeah,
it's quagmired in greed and built on a
foundation of unfixable bullshit,
but it still spiraling towards the
technological singularity question about
it.
Some of the advancements that you're
talking about are some of the things
that you're like,
wow,
things have really advanced.
It's because groups of people made
active efforts to push against the and
a,
the anti evolutionary for
sure.
I mean that's their role in this
machine.
That's their role in this,
this process,
this,
the,
you know,
their,
their role is to,
to push things in that manner.
No,
I mean I think it's all an ingredient in
a gigantic metaphysical sort of a soup
and it's all piled in together there and
know when everyone's doing their little
part,
but it's changing slow for our,
our ideas and our tastes.
But in,
as you know,
in compared to history that the rapid
pace of evolution and the evolution of
progress,
the complexification of our society,
it's blowing up in our face.
We're hanging on tooth and nail.
Literally,
you know,
there's a lot of people that still have
even grasped how much it's changed.
That's why when you have all these Wacko
Gay Republican dudes,
they get busted online,
getting hookers,
you know,
getting male hookers like this new guy
that just got caught.
Somebody just sent it to me on twitter.
I don't know his fucking name,
but you know the story.
The story just keeps happening over and
over again.
The same goddamn story.
This guy wanted to pay some dude to have
sex with him and he got caught with it
and it's fascinating.
It's fascinating shit.
Human animals,
a very strange mixture of complex
thinking and awareness and then some
just wild monkey jealousy and instincts
and fears and it's all piled together in
this weird fucking biological machine
and it just like God figure this out.
We've got a bunch of things pulling you
a bunch of different directions and a
lot of eyes are on you.
Good luck and just get pushed out there
and try to find things to sustain the
body while the mind searches for answers
and likeminded people to hang with in
order to compare idea so you don't feel
like you're crazy.
You don't feel like you're the only
person out there.
On the beach howling at the moon saying,
what the fuck is this?
Somebody please make sense of this shit.
Somebody is there anybody out there in
the Internet now you can send that
fucking message in a bottle and someone
answers,
dude right here,
WTF?
What the fuck?
What's going on?
What's happening?
And everybody gets together and that's
the hive mind.
That's how the mind really thickens.
That's how things really start getting
connected to happening.
Right now.
It's only we're only dealing with a two
decade old invention.
Two decades is a fucking a fraction of
the time it takes for your eyes to
close,
but how about when?
Not only does it get a grip of people
being like,
what the fuck?
How about,
how about when it brings groups of
people into the streets and overthrows
governments like in Egypt.
I mean it doesn't just stop with
how about the UK?
One of the things that we're trying to
do,
they want to shut down twitter and
facebook over there because that's how
people were communicating this bart
thing that happened at San Francisco to
shut down the fucking cell phones.
They didn't want people organizing.
Yeah,
it's crazy,
man.
I like that kind of shit is like,
listen man,
you can't do that.
You can't.
You're not allowed to shut off the
phones.
What if someone's fucking mother was
dying?
What if someone got hit by a car but you
couldn't call fucking ambulance because
you can't use your phone because you
assholes are afraid of criticism because
you assholes are afraid of people
yelling and screaming and telling you
that you fucked up so you cut off the
phone lines.
You should go to jail.
If you shut off the phones in America in
2011 to avoid a protest,
fuck you.
That's ridiculous for you to say that
you want to maintain order so badly,
you will cut off communication between
everyone.
Tax payers with good people that have
done no wrong without a single spot on
their record.
You deny them use of the phone to
blanketly.
Fuck you.
You know what they said?
What?
Humans have American,
have a right to free speech,
but they also have a right to get to
where they want to go on time.
Yeah.
Well,
how about if someone's dying suit?
No,
I think it's the worst.
I think it's a,
it's fucking.
So it's,
to me it's scary.
It's terrifying,
terrifying,
terrifying.
It's scary because it's like,
which you're supposed to do is you're
going to have to hire more cops,
stupid.
And you gonna have to,
you know,
keep peace in a,
in a very respectful manner.
And you know,
there's a,
there's a whole fucking bad history
which we cops and people up there,
man.
And you know,
I'm not saying that the cops are 100
percent in the wrong,
but there's been some shit they did.
That's crazy.
Like the cop that shot the guy because
he thought it was tasering him instead
he shot them and it's all on video.
I mean look what the fuck,
man.
There's been a lot of nonsense like
that.
And just when you shut the fucking
phones off and keep people from
protesting,
people just got to go,
what,
what the fuck are you doing?
And who the fuck are you?
That's why it's so incredible what
anonymous did by creating a protest that
got broadcast nationally to every
internationally people saw that shit.
And,
and if they hadn't have done that,
if they'd been content with just having
conversations about it,
it wouldn't have escalated to the level
that it is escalated to.
And a lot of those guys got arrested.
Like they put freedom of information in
front of their own freedom.
That is heroic.
That's bad ass.
That's what I'm talking about.
I'm saying at some point you people have
got to like stand up because if you
don't.
If no one had stood up,
no one had done that.
If there'd been no protests,
if Bart didn't know that every time they
tried to shut the fucking phone lines
down,
they're gonna get swarmed.
Was the,
what was the protest over,
do you know?
I don't know that it was.
They were putting the,
the anonymous protest was after another
protest that happened.
And I do not know why the first protest
happened.
I just know they shut the fuck up.
Did it have to do with that guy who was
murdered?
I think that the guys getting out of
jail a column,
maybe I might be completely different.
That's what I thought the whole thing
was about the time.
It's just so satisfying the world.
And when you think about that,
someone lost their life because of
something so fucking stupid.
And then the guy who did it,
the one fucking stupid mistake,
his life is fucked forever too.
Yeah.
He's got to deal with that for the rest.
I mean,
can you imagine what it is?
How stupid you must feel to make that
mistake.
You're so panicked.
You thought you had your Taser,
but you had your gun and you shot the
guy.
That weight of that.
Think of the weight of that.
I always think about that,
the weight,
because it's like when you fuck over a
friend or if you do something stupid,
eventually you can say,
I'm sorry.
That was stupid.
You can apologize and you can get it off
your chest when you kill somebody.
You can't do it.
You can apologize.
Someone back to live.
There's nothing you can do.
You can say you're sorry to their
family,
but that's not going to bring the person
back.
It's so terrible.
Yeah,
it's pretty crazy idea.
We're so connected to each other.
What?
You lose someone in your life so,
so painful.
The idea that other people can take
people away from people.
That's like the ultimate attack on them.
So strange because we all know are
temporary.
We all know we're going to die.
We just don't want to right now.
I'm not ready yet.
Now I'm moving too much fun.
I'm enjoying this.
I'm just.
I'm just getting this thing mastered.
I'm just getting it figured out.
I know how to enjoy it.
Now.
I figured it out.
I figured out how to enjoy.
Don't let me die yet.
No,
not yet.
Sorry.
Mr Rogen.
We've got to move you onto the next
experiment.
You can't stay here.
That's,
you know,
that's like.
Maybe that's all it is.
It's like when they give like the planet
of the Apes,
you know when they have that,
the spoiler alert,
your fingers in your ears don't do it.
It's not that bad.
I can talk about the tests that they
did.
Right.
Can I talk about it?
Talk about the plot is probably not
smart.
That's rude.
Okay.
So forget planet of the apes.
But sometimes the kids you give them
like intelligence tests where they have
to like do like certain things you know
and,
and imagine if that's what this whole
thing is,
some kind of alien intelligence tests
where after you solve the puzzle,
you get moved along and the way it looks
when you get moved along is you,
you're gone day taking a bullet in the
chest or your,
you know,
your,
some,
you're someone who just like maybe you
just have a heart attack.
Like sometimes I've thought I wonder if
there's like a thought you can have or a
place you can get to where you just get
it to the point where you don't have to
stick around here.
Like they say that some yogis through
meditation have just like meditated and
meditated and they can willfully just
leave their body.
They call it dropping your body.
They don't call it death dropping your
body.
I wouldn't.
I wouldn't put that past the realm of
possibility.
Have you considered the fact that your
brain,
we know produces a bunch of different
psychedelic chemicals?
Who's to say that it's not some way to
trigger those are not the way it is.
Some way to stimulate those,
but putting yourself into a frequency
through meditation where you force the
brain to accept a certain vibe,
a certain just a certain frequency,
and in doing so you can actually force
your brain into producing certain
chemicals and then you'd fucking blast
off in the brain.
Makes psychedelics fact,
fact.
The human
body makes psychedelics fact.
We know it does.
It makes a bunch of things that affect
your behavior.
It makes adrenaline,
makes dopamine,
Serotonin,
so all these different things that
oxytocin.
There's all sorts of things that
stimulate you,
affect you,
and we know it makes all the crazy
chemicals that exist,
that create the dream state kind of been
taking this Fuckin Alpha brain shit and
having the nuttiest dreams.
Man and I had a werewolf,
gorilla sex dream.
It was the strangest fucking dream of
all time.
It was so bizarre because it was so
stupid,
but so real and so easy to recall this,
these,
these Alpha brain things.
Man.
One of the things that a bunch of people
tweeted me about this too,
that when you,
uh,
when you take them and have dreams for
whatever reason,
you're fucking,
you remember your dreams,
you know,
and um,
this dream was so stupid.
It was a gorilla and he was right behind
like a bulging and breaking piece of
wallboard.
You know,
that white plaster.
And I had a squirt the,
uh,
the,
the fucking stuff to put them to sleep
through it.
I couldn't go and get to him that I had
to run away and hide.
And he ran into a werewolf and they
fucking fought and then started sucking
each other's cocks.
Was the most ridiculous dream ever.
I'm not reasonable.
I Dunno what the fuck it means,
but there's Werewolf was on top sucking
this gorillas cock and there were like
69 and I was like,
what kind?
I've never had a dream like that before.
Where I was.
He looked into dream dictionary doesn't
exist.
You are Joe Rogan.
Yeah,
it was.
It was so crazy.
It was like going from an absolute
terror and fear like there was these,
these gorillas were these giant silver
backs and they were right behind this
thin piece of wallboard and I had to
inject them with this,
the sedative.
I had to get them with it and I couldn't
quite get to them and I pulled it out
and he came through the wall and I ran
as I ran out and then he runs into the
little girl.
It was just,
it went from 69 became completely
ridiculous.
Not only that,
but the way they looked became
completely ridiculous.
They went from being like a terrifying
looking silver back gorilla to some sort
of curious George halfway into,
you know,
goofy looking like smiling gorilla,
getting his dick sucked by a Werewolf,
you know?
It became completely cartoonish.
It was so strange.
I was like,
I can't even wrap my head around how
anybody would try to describe,
how are you going to tell me what's
going on in my head?
That's how are you going to,
to when it,
everything became a big gay joke.
It's like you're running from,
you're running from a terrifying
superior physical specimen in a giant
silver back gorilla that you're trying
to sedate through a wall with a needle
and then you run away and then a
werewolf turns a corner and smashes into
the grill and then they start blowing
each other the fuck man.
Better get.
Do you do believe in those dream books
that's not in there?
I don't believe it.
That's in a dream book.
I'll and I'll tell you what,
God,
I'm fucking straight as they come.
That's not,
that's not what this is about.
Um,
I am just a not responsible for a lot of
the thoughts that spin around in my
imagination.
Sometimes.
I really don't believe I am.
I think,
I mean,
it's not that I was thinking that this
was a real thing.
It was like my brain just created the
stupidest idea for them
movie in the middle of a horrifying
scenario scenario.
Like now,
did you join into the,
into the monkeys at all?
Did you start having sex with them or
trying to get away?
I was trying to get away and they were
just blowing each other.
Oh wait,
no escape.
Yeah,
yeah.
They started blowing each other and then
I said,
okay,
I can get outta here.
But it became like cartoon.
Should you walk away slow like watching
the whole time here.
I tiptoed so it didn't shock them,
you know,
I feel like if you move too fast they
can't help but chase,
you
roll a ball of yarn past a kitten,
they run after it.
They can't help themselves.
It's just instinctual.
They say that's what also happens with
bikers,
mountain bikers and mountain lions.
Sometimes mountain lions is see them
moving fast and they literally can't
help themselves.
They just chase after him.
Right?
So you want to make sure you don't do
that.
So I walked away real slow and they were
blowing each other.
So there you go.
You guys.
There's a survival tip.
Yeah.
If you ever come upon a werewolf
allowing a gorilla gorilla sucking each
other's cocks.
Same.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
Good luck,
Freud.
Good luck.
Disecting that memory or that,
uh,
that idea.
But the weird thing is that it was so
vivid.
These pills,
for whatever reason,
give you these incredibly vivid dreams.
What,
um,
what's in them?
Good question.
I should probably know,
right?
Telling everybody to take them.
It's a supposedly a everything.
There's,
there's a on on it.com,
o n n I t dangerous,
or Aubrey as he says.
Would you say Angel Eyes?
Yeah.
People keep on saying there's Angel
Angel Eyes.
What does that mean?
It is that stuff that you give to dogs.
So when they,
they tear it makes it,
you know,
when dog cries,
it gets black underneath their eyes.
Angel Eyes is something that you put in
their food when they eat,
so it doesn't.
It takes that away and people on online
is like,
does it have angel was.
I've never knew that there was something
like people are going to serve with
their dogs tiers.
Yeah.
When you get like a white dog and it's
really spraying that yellow shit out.
Looks like,
but what the fuck are you doing to the
dog?
What does that mean?
They're protein.
It's like a too much zinc or something
weird like that.
So it's just sort of holistic.
Yeah.
Okay.
Where the fuck are we talking about
before?
Angel eyes are telling him about it.
60 nine werewolf gorilla did do other.
Begin from that to Angel Eyes.
You're talking about the brain stuff,
the pills,
the brain pills.
Who knows what they're doing to us.
Your.
Yeah.
Your sales pitch for the pills.
I think we got to work on it a little
bit.
Working on it.
No,
I'm not selling it.
This is what I'm telling you this.
This is what I've decided to do.
I'm just going to be totally honest with
how I feel them.
That's my.
I'm going to give my pr.
I'm not a doctor.
Obviously,
if you're listening to any medical
advice I'd give you.
You're a silly person.
There's plenty of valid sources on the
Internet,
but I am a person with an objective
experience and what I'll do is I'll take
these fucking pills and I'll tell you
what I feel like and what I feel like
right now is I feel like they make.
My mind feels clearer and clearer is a
very subjective term obviously,
but I feel like I have more energy,
but it doesn't feel like a run on sort
of a spiky caffeine energy.
It feels like it.
I hate the word crisp and cleaner,
but that's for lack of better word.
Enough of energy.
Yeah.
It does something good,
man.
I,
I enjoy it and it gives me very
memorable dreams.
Not all of them involving gorillas and
wearable.
If some of them been weird.
People dreams have some science fiction
dreams.
You know,
I've had some.
I've had some crazy ones.
I had this crazy dream about a world
with a thousand Nikola Tesla's that
instead of just one super genius
oddball,
crazy man like tesla,
this,
it was like a subsect of the species and
it was like a thousand of them and they
just in a matter of a few years time had
these giant metal floating ships all
throughout cities and everything was run
through wireless electricity and this
was me somehow or another in the 19
fifties,
this 1000 teslas had moved society so
rapidly before anybody could even
control it because they were so far
advanced.
It was like a thousand of them
altogether creating all this shit.
And in the 19 fifties there was flying
ships and you know,
there was a type of electronic
connectivity that was very similar to
the way we're doing it now,
but different.
It was just everyone could talk to
people from these handsets that we're
all throughout the city.
Like there were,
there were,
you know,
everyone was congested at this one place
and you could move to any handset and
constantly be contacting people.
It's very trippy,
man.
It was really weird because it was like
19 fifties aesthetic,
like the way people dress and you know,
a man going to work with a leather
briefcase and you know,
and,
and even like the certain type of hats,
they would wear it with their glasses
on.
Father knows best for me.
Mother is flying metal ships and no
electricity in the air.
Now Tesla wanted to broadcast
electricity.
He wanted it to be like,
well,
radio signals and have it just fly
through the air.
But then anybody could just like radio,
just all you need is a receiver to take
it.
There was no fucking money in that.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
He had a lot of shit that he invented
that,
you know,
they took away his trunks that all his
writing.
Yeah.
It's Kinda fascinating.
Fascinating dude.
But in this crazy dream,
the dream like almost had a title of a
thousand Teslas has it.
There was all these little crazy looking
dudes,
eccentric looking super geniuses running
around all together.
Like if I was creating all this nutty
shit and no one could keep up with what
the effects,
it was just,
it was nothing like the slower pace that
we've had to endure over,
you know,
and really,
and you think about an extra half of a
century and shit,
it's really not that much time ever to
have all this,
uh,
new technology together.
But if at all burst together in the 19
fifties,
if we had every,
all the access to,
to all the different disciplines that we
have today,
if we have them in the 19 fifties,
if there was really like that kind of an
evolutionary growth like immediately
from 1900 dash,
1950,
that'd be incredible.
That'd be so fascinating.
If in a lifetime we go from 1900 to us
right now or advance or even more
advanced in 50 years.
Yeah.
Like if the singularity happens in the
fifties.
Exactly.
Do you believe in the multiverse stuff?
I'm stupid.
I'm too stupid to argue about it.
I read,
um,
some new thing about,
I forget what it was that made them
believe that some sort of a,
some sort of sound,
something vibration.
What was the,
the latest.
There's some latest evidence of a
multiverse.
What do you know,
what it is now on the Internet?
It's all still.
What if though I.
that's the only bad thing about the
whole thing.
We're never going to probably find out
in our lifetime.
I don't know,
man.
If you look back,
if you want to see how much we've
advanced,
just go back like we were talking about
earlier and check out the medical idea.
People have this scientific ideas.
People at here it is right here.
First observational test of the
multiverse.
The theory that our universe is
contained inside a bubble and that
bubble,
that multiple alternate universes exist
inside their own bubbles making up the
multiverse is for the first time being
tested by physicists to research papers
published in physical review letters and
physical review.
D are the first detail how to search for
signatures of other universes.
Physicists are now searching for
disliked patterns in the cosmic
microwave.
Background,
relic,
heat radiation leftover from the Big
Bang,
which could provide telltale evidence of
collisions between other universes in
our own whoa.
Collisions,
evidence of collisions of universes.
What the fuck dude collisions.
That's the alternative concept to the
Big Bang as well.
The idea that our universe,
whether it's in a bubble like the
multiverse or the people that proposed
membranes,
they proposed that the brains collide at
certain points and that creates like a
recycling of the of the world.
We just can't wrap our head around
something that's that far or that long,
that much longer,
uh,
a period of existence than our own life.
The idea of this cycle that's billions
and billions of years.
We are so important in our own lives
that the idea that that's how small
apart we play for real.
I'm going to exist for 80 years inside
some weird biological body and some
crazy process that happens every 16,
$17,
billion years.
These things collide with each other and
everything starts completely from new.
No planets,
man,
no nothing.
Just particles and gas and heat and
nuclear explosions and fucking mass
connects all these different objects
together.
And they slowly formed planets and then
live grows on them,
and then life becomes complex.
Life becomes intelligent,
self-aware,
life creates technology,
goes to war,
blows up the fucking universe,
and then they collide again and more
collide all around.
And it's a constant cycle of you
society,
life.
Everything in the universe,
complexity gets to a certain peak and
then just they just hit each other.
Maybe it's not that much time in between
each collision.
Maybe it's not.
Maybe a genius thought are really great
idea when people have like super great
ideas,
maybe that's a collision,
a collision that's happened,
maybe like maybe,
uh,
maybe,
maybe it happens on the micro scale and
not just on the macro scale.
It's like perhaps there's like super
tiny universe is that bubble again and
again,
stars and like manifest in the form of
somebody who came up with the theory of
relativity or some kind of Gullah
culture shaping idea like communism or
something like that.
Maybe that every great idea is just a
projection of the multiverse coming
through people and manifesting here is
massive global change and maybe we're
getting hit by more of them now like a
media or swarm of these multi.
These other universes bumping into ours.
Falcon Mckenna wrote this awesome,
weird story.
Did you ever read this thing?
He talked about how it is right around
when Christianity started,
the universe ripped into a multiverse
and there's another advanced dimension
right next to ours that's concerned over
the fact that we have nuclear weapons,
but like normally we can be ignored,
but the fact we have nuclear weapons
kind of like makes things in multiverse
is next to us that are aware of is
worried,
but he wrote it not like it was really
wrote it in this strange way.
Like I couldn't tell if he was trying to
write a metaphor or something.
I just don't want to find it is fucking
cool,
but this tesla thing you're talking
about.
It's so funny because you have to think,
okay,
well I guess my brain just completely
manufactured this alternate reality or
super intelligent people that invented
all these things.
That's like one version of it or the
other version which a lot of I think
shamans talk about his idea of the
spirit world where that moment your
astral body went to some alternate
dimension and sow one possibility of the
way our universe could have turned out
and then came back here and now you're
broadcasting that.
Say as many people as listening,
listen to the show.
You're a leak of some weird,
some weird coordinate of the multiverse
is coming through you now as you talk
about this thing that's like it's a
dream.
Maybe there's some fucking part of the
multiverse where where will 69 gorillas
stay the fuck away
away from there.
It just.
To me it was almost like a little
message that everything is preposterous.
Do you take.
Do you ever stop and wonder how much
of
your life,
how much of the things that you go
through are real and how much of it may
be some sort of a background noise going
on in this weird play that you're
creating for yourself to your
imagination has put forth and then
Sunday you're going to understand it
all,
but right now it's all the people that
are in front of you or the bit players
and you're supposed to be trying to
figure this thing out as you move along.
All that stuff that's going on in the
background car accidents
or seems like there's so many pieces
going together to like too to too many
times.
I'm like,
that's just weird that that just
happened like that.
You know,
like it just seems like it's just
manifesting things in your own mind.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's not,
it's not a fault.
It's not foolproof.
You know?
It's not like he could prove it.
Right,
but there's something going on.
Yeah,
I think it is.
I think there,
there there's something to the idea that
we're like,
when you know someone's going to call
you and then you pick up the phone and
it's them.
That's just weird.
There's something to that.
I don't know what it is.
I'm not,
but I don't buy that.
It's just coincidence.
It may be coincidence sometimes,
but I've had sharp moments where I
thought of somebody and I looked at the
phone.
It started ringing and it was like sharp
moments.
Like I don't know what that is.
I don't know what it is.
You could say that.
It's just luck in anticipation of
meeting each other.
You know that I was hoping that person
called me,
but not even man.
Sometimes you don't even think about
that person for a long time.
Then all sudden you think about them
like,
wow,
I haven't talked to him in fucking 10
years,
and then he leaves you an email and
you're like,
what is that?
What is
it just happened to me?
Dude,
I just on the lab under our.
I just did.
My friend Brendan Walsh came in and we
both go to the same medicinal marijuana
dispensary and we're both talking about
how awesome it is and the people that
work there really fucking cool and so
I'm like,
you know what,
I'm going to do a commercial for this
dispensary.
Like I want to do like a all the way
commercial should be.
I'm not getting paid.
They don't even know who I am.
I'm just going to do this commercial
because they're cool people and a cool
fucking place.
So I,
I did like little,
like there's a character on a Webinar or
a teacup pig is basically little Hobo.
I,
I did this stupid commercial for them.
The next day I went in there to get my
medicine and I walked in and the guy's
like,
Hey,
I look at this,
look at this,
and he just pulled up on the computer,
the lavender,
our episode where I did the
advertisement.
Now what the fuck are the odds that the
odds of that are pretty God damn slim.
I mean,
it's.
I think the odds that that guy would
even hear it are pretty slim.
But if you consider the idea of me
coming there at the exact time,
you just pull it up on the computer.
Dude,
I don't think you have any idea how many
people listened to you on this podcast.
I bet probably was a big pothead podcast
fan and he probably listens to this one
or listens to yours and he knew exactly
who the fuck you were and he,
he seen you online because he thought
you were hilarious.
When I find out that about a comedian of
someone that I think is funny or a
musician or some new music like I got,
I just got into Queens,
queens of the Stone Age,
every slab and looking up on them and
reading different articles about them
and downloaded a couple of their cds.
It's great stuff.
But when you then you all of a sudden
you know what that person looks like if
you recognize them.
So if this guy was like a lavender,
our
fan wasn't.
His friend had told him about it.
I'm just saying that weird temporal
coincidence of me.
I even tried to pee on your parade.
The parade.
I want it to be the voice of logic of
all.
I mean this was,
but I more people listen to your show
and the lavender are for one too.
You got to get rid of that broad.
Get outta here.
Holy Shit.
I was like,
man,
don't go down
please.
Man.
People love those kinds of shows.
Jay Moore does it with his girl and
everybody.
There was an article on our website
about,
um,
uh,
what's his face?
Who the fuck does it with his girl,
uh,
Gilbert,
Jesus Christ,
Bill Burr and his girlfriend would get
into arguments and he doesn't want his
Monday morning podcast.
There was a whole thread about how they
love it when bill burrs girlfriend comes
on because it's fun.
It's a,
it's A.
I think that's some of the funniest
moments when we start arguing.
Kevin Smith,
his wife.
That was an interesting one.
It's,
it's,
you know,
it's a different dynamic man.
You know,
husband and wives have weird dynamics.
Men and women.
We're dynamics,
you know,
uh,
doing yours.
I love doing your podcast.
It was fun.
It was fun seeing you in this different
environment,
you know,
because whenever you and I do a podcast,
we do it over here,
but doing it over there,
it was cool to see,
you know,
you and her have this real cute little
banter thing going back and forth and
we're all sitting in this thing together
and you have to stop every 20 minutes
because it's a,
it's about to crash your hard drive.
Like it's like so totally dunk.
It's like,
oh,
this is awesome.
It's awesome.
Hold on guys.
I got to say this,
I got to say this.
This is gold.
Hold up.
So every 20 minutes
saving it on his fucking hear that sound
effect.
We fixed it,
we fixed it.
You know what I like.
This is what I really liked about it.
She and you are very different,
but she lets you be you.
She's not trying to change you and
you're such an odd guy.
Dunkin and I've,
you know,
we've had,
you've had situations in the past where
girls did kind of get that,
that was good and they wanted to turn
you into something else.
Like do you remember the time when you
were thinking about quitting comedy and
you're going to go back to school?
Yeah,
because every time I get on the show,
you'll remind me and everyone about it.
It was.
It was a brilliant moment.
Yeah,
it was a beautiful moment.
It was.
It was a moment,
which I don't mind by the way.
I was joking.
I don't know.
I know.
I know,
but who were you dating?
Sigourney weaver.
Those moments when you realize that
someone is morphing you and then you are
trying to conform to what they like
because you don't want them to leave
you.
Those are creepy fucking weird moments
that that's terrible or scary moments.
Those are scary fucking moments because.
Because.
Well they are all.
You know what they are.
It's an illusion of being scary because
you know,
I mean,
well,
no,
it isn't.
I mean for some people,
what happens if you put a baby inside
one of those people?
What happens if like,
yes,
that's.
Then then you're connected forever.
You're chained to a person who's this
satisfied with you as a human,
but here's the thing.
They're being with someone for awhile,
you're,
you're going to watch people go through
phases and they're going to be some
phases that people are in it maybe
you're not so cool with,
you know what I mean?
And you have to differentiate between is
this person or am I dissatisfied with
some core aspect of this human or are
they just in a weird spot right now?
And I got to see,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it's tricky because
you and your chick or unusual in that
you're both in the same line of business
and you work together and you still get
along.
Yeah.
How the fuck does that happen?
Um,
doesn't always happen.
It doesn't always happen.
We don't always get along.
We're not in a,
we have a great relationship.
But if you think that.
I mean,
relationships aren't idyllic,
you know what I mean?
But what is it like,
like you're mean and you open for her,
right?
Yes.
Well that's kind of your feature for
multiple sale,
right?
I'll open for whatever.
I do open a lot of shit.
Open car doors for open.
Everything is open fucking cans.
What I'm trying to say,
she's a good comic too.
She's a great comic and she's fucking
disciplined and really funny.
And when we work together we are synergy
creates a lot of funny shit and,
and I'm,
and I make her laugh and she's got one
of the greatest lines I've ever heard.
And so that keeps me wanting to be funny
around her and instead of it like her
rejecting me being funny.
She embraces it.
And so then you've got girls reject you
being funny.
Uh,
I would,
I wouldn't say like reject me being
funny,
but I think it's more of a,
it's more with her.
Is it a conformity thing?
Like they wanted you to like,
I know it's always crazy power,
man.
It's not a conformity thing.
It's like you're either in a
relationship with somebody where you can
create a symbiosis and merge your power
together and you both want each other to
be successful or you're in a situation
with someone where somebody wants to be
on top.
Somebody wants to be at.
Someone wants to be literally on top in
every single way.
And so if you're in a relationship where
somebody is trying to repress your
creativity out of fear,
then as a human being,
you have to,
you have to get out of that
relationship.
But it's not that easy.
You're in love with somebody.
What do you.
What do you mean by what you were just
saying?
Someone that always wants to be on top,
on top,
on top of the game,
on,
on top of you in every way.
Dominant.
The dominant one.
The if,
if you're with someone who you've had
that man.
Oh yeah,
I would say you did want to hear
that one's full on someone just
constantly fucking with you.
Constantly.
Time for that.
Really,
I think.
I think the important thing to realize
that she has a vagina is not a life of
hell,
but it's true.
They're fucking shades of this that
we're talking about.
There's shades of this and,
and I,
and the reason it's kind of a common,
you know,
it's a common thing when you see in a
sitcom or a movie.
The theme of that got yes,
dear.
Whatever she wants is what goes.
It's because we're talking about a some
form of interaction that happens between
the masculine and feminine
energies.
Will,
you don't,
it's really interesting.
Um,
you,
you've grown more.
It's true.
You've grown more as a person.
I mean,
you,
you've always been a guy who's really
pretty introspective and kind of
brutally honest about yourself,
pro or con.
But when you're in a steady
relationship,
I always feel like,
especially like right now,
like you're in a healthy one,
you,
you're in a,
you're in a way different place
creatively.
Like you're able to express yourself
without the burden of.
There's a lot of psychological fucking
warfare that goes on and constantly bad
relationships that really clouds up the
mind.
And when you're in a healthy
relationship,
you know,
like you are,
it allows you to think about things much
clearer.
Your ability to describe reality just
over the past few years,
you've gotten so much better at it.
Man,
you're,
you're writing's gotten better.
Your comedies gotten better.
You've always been a super smart dude,
but I think that when,
when you're in a position where you,
you find someone who doesn't try to
fucking change who you are is so
important.
So worst thing in the world,
is he one of your friends stuck in some
situation where someone's trying to get
him to be something that he's not right,
not encourage them to do what he wants
to do,
but to get them to.
You're never going to make it as a
comedian.
Just give this up.
Yeah.
The thing about you can write books.
I get encouraged like that.
Yeah.
It's a very cool relationship because
the income I get encouraged to go on
stage more.
You got to go on stage more.
You gotta go up all the time.
You gotta work harder.
Why you get onstage?
Do you had to do standup?
Go on the road,
get a headlining sets,
like a really good situation for sure.
Yeah,
but you know,
if
she was married to some square dude
who's like,
you know,
fucking accountant or something like
that.
It's like,
you know her interests and needs and
weirdness and probably be too much for
him.
You know what I mean?
It's like you guys meet at the perfect
time,
your weirdness in your,
your creativity.
She understands it.
She gets it.
She gets what you're doing.
She gets that this is a gonna result in
you killing on stage.
Whereas someone who doesn't see you as
being successful enough things that they
can fix you and mold you and turn you
into something respectable.
They can bring it parties.
Oh,
this is my boyfriend Duncan.
He's a professor at Cornell.
What do you teach?
Uh,
you know,
mostly ancient history,
but a philosophy.
Can I get you another tree,
you know,
and you got those suede patches on your
elbows and you're just thinking about
telling a great suck my cock joke and
killing in front of a large crowd at the
comedy store on a Friday night,
a nice 10:00
spot.
You're crushing you thinking about that
while you're hanging out with some
dildos,
some stupid house where they eat French
cheese had come in their pants.
Wow.
The second part.
And then you watch two monkeys,
fuck,
I knew a dude from France and him and
his wife became friends with them and
they had me over for some weird dish
that they have with non pasteurized
cheeses and he was like really adamant
about that,
that when they homogenized and
pasteurized cheese in America fucks up
the flavor.
So he has to sneak this shit over.
Illegal cheese.
Yeah.
He actually sneaks it over.
Wow.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He puts it in some,
a container that says it's pasteurizer
modular as they have people that will do
it for them because it's stinks.
It was kind of was bacteria in it,
you know,
but it's so good.
And that's what.
I'm sorry.
But that's what blue cheese is.
You look at those crumbles.
The blue cheese,
the blue part.
That's like fun.
Can Mold.
Why would it be illegal though?
Just because it's considered like a
poison or something?
Good question.
Um,
I think it's a really good question.
I think just for public health concerns,
when you,
uh,
when you like raw milk,
it's like real dangerous.
You can only keep it for a certain
amount of time.
Now,
how long is it good.
For me,
regular milk is good for like a month.
Raw milk can be good for more than like
seven or nine days or something like
that.
I would imagine.
And you know,
people can get sick,
you know?
I think that's,
that's some of the theory behind it is
that it when you homogenize things
pasteurized and you can pick them,
keep them on the shelf longer,
but that's also how you apparently
cooked the enzymes.
That's one of the reasons why people
have lactose intolerance,
but some people with lactose intolerance
can actually drink raw milk and not have
any problems with it.
Weird.
Yeah.
But raw milk tastes delicious dude.
Raw whole milk.
It's like really?
It tastes really good.
Like with cookies.
Oh it's the shit.
It's so like rich and creamy and you
know,
it seems so alive when you drink it as
opposed to like,
you know when you drink regular,
homogenized,
pasteurized milk.
This is milk,
body,
dead milk,
water,
Whitewater thing.
It's not so weird but comes from a cow.
This cheese that I got in Paris,
God,
you sound like a jerk when you talk like
this.
You sound like such a jerk.
But this cheese I had,
it was like talk.
It was not,
it was not just like a little bit of
mold.
Like you'll get cheesy and you'll see
the green stuff.
It was like flourishing more like when
you leave,
like just rising above the cheese,
just like blowing with mold and it was
so good.
You just ate the whole diarrhea or weird
feelings.
I don't even want to talk about.
Really.
I don't even want to talk about what I
did do at June.
Why would you even eat that?
You made so you had all this delicious
food and you got mad diarrhea and you're
trying to get us to eat it.
It wasn't diarrhea.
It was something worse for it.
Did you do your girl get it to.
No,
I don't think so.
Did she eat the same stuff you ate?
Yeah.
If she got it,
she didn't tell me.
Well good.
That's good.
That's nice.
You can wear that like this is.
I don't want to tell us.
She's a good girl.
I had it.
It was very intense what it did to my
stomach.
Dude,
there's nothing wrong with a good shit
story.
I always in this jazz club in Paris and
I have,
first of all,
if you say that to the right girl you're
in.
Not when I followed up with this.
Okay.
I,
I like what I did to the bathroom
because like when I got up,
after I'd finished,
I'm trying to make this as not.
When I was done with my shit and I
looked back at the toilet,
it was like a shit bazooka.
Come Adam.
It was like everything was just
everything.
Like I like,
it was crazy where I,
I panicked.
I was like,
Oh God,
I gotta get Outta here.
Get outta here.
Someone walks in here now I might get
arrested so much shit.
They would arrest you for oversharing.
Look him in the clinic.
Yeah.
Girls share poop.
A pictures with each other.
It's just like guys don't really.
They take pictures of their poo,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
This is a world.
Women should be allowed.
The freedom of shock.
Shocking people with a giant poops.
I love him.
I wish I could put them online.
I wish I could put my pictures online.
You can fuck Outta here.
Nothing stopping you.
Just intelligence.
Hey,
you're going to be in a New Orleans to
see your shit man.
I don't want to get upset when.
When I,
when I see people's Shit.
I don't know.
I'm going to see it.
Yeah,
I'm going to be in New Orleans.
Yeah.
You got to check out this restaurant in
New Orleans.
It's,
it's crazy.
It's called oceans.
Uh,
when I tell you right now,
I just started thinking about those
catacombs.
Ocean,
ocean,
restaurant,
ocean.
It.
I just saw the show on the woman CEO
owns it.
Tried to trick me.
Is it really,
you know,
they were on that show I was talking
about once a kitchen nightmares and you
got to watch a season for it.
Last episode of season four,
but the guy on there is and almost tried
to beat up,
uh,
the chef and then the,
the,
the kitchen man or the head chef had
like some seizure thing going on with
his face and they fired him on the show
anyways.
They're completely crazy.
And so sometimes when people are on that
show,
I'll go on yelp to see if like their
business is,
you know,
like in business and stuff like that or
see what the reviews now or,
and on their yelp right now it's like
110.
We came with 110 people were trying to
negotiate the bill,
like manager went psycho called cops on
and start throwing things screaming.
And so you watch this episode and then
you look at the yelp.
This might be the craziest fucking place
ever to go to.
Wow.
You got it.
And then you look at their website and
it's like a friendly website,
like the happiest thing in the world.
It's crazy.
Have you ever been there before?
New Orleans?
Yes.
A long time ago I was there,
uh,
for a UFC.
It was,
who knows God when nobody knew what the
UFC was back then.
It was during the news radio days.
Yeah.
I don't remember much,
man.
We'll put on some fights and left when
we were eight of the restaurant and
people were saying,
be careful.
It's dangerous.
That's what I kept hearing,
Blah.
Be careful.
It's dangerous.
People kept saying,
be careful.
It's dangerous.
People get robbed.
There's apparently a extraordinary
amount of crime around New Orleans.
My Dad would take me to New Orleans.
He'd go to a bar,
he gave me like 60 bucks.
I get fucking drunk and wander down the
street and just take nitrous oxide
heads.
Hold on a second.
How old are you?
I think I was like 16,
15.
I don't know what.
That's what I used to do.
16 to.
Yeah.
I would go down the street and get.
Because you could buy nitrous oxide
balloons.
So I,
I,
this is how bad kid I was.
I spent all my money on a stripper and
all these nitrous oxide balloons and
some booze.
So I know it money that was supposed to
last for a couple of days that my dad
had given me and then I told my dad I
got mugged him.
More money to spend on more nitrogen
oxide.
Is that crazy easy with corporation,
half of their profit is just from people
doing balloons.
It's not crazy.
Come on.
Half the profit that.
I mean that has to be.
I used to bike,
but you were reading something online.
I'm sure man.
I bet it's not even one percent.
No Way.
No,
no.
Sixteen year olds.
Sixteen year olds do it.
Out of 100.
How many people do you know that make
their own whipped cream?
Yeah,
exactly.
Awesome.
Here's some homemade whipped cream.
Everyone enjoy.
I made this myself
couple of times and it is delicious.
I don't.
I think most people by the web stuff,
don't get me wrong,
but I've made it a couple times.
It's pretty bad.
Okay.
Start.
You got to get one of those blenders
things was to whisks.
They spend with each other and you get
it a bowl and you add all the
ingredients.
I've done it a couple times.
It's pretty dope.
Real whipped cream tastes better because
you know,
just.
But you know,
come on man,
I ain't making this shit.
I don't have the time for that.
But the stuff that's in the cans that
doesn't taste as good,
that doesn't care.
She's good as trump.
Like if you go to a real restaurant and
get some real whipped cream
with strawberries.
When I see a can of whipped cream to
this day,
all I think about is how it comes to my
mind when I see a can of whipped cream,
when I will use to my.
I had a friend in high school introduced
me to whippets and after that I don't
know if my parents thought I was trying
to become a pastry chef.
What the fuck they thought in Ohio,
they sold it everywhere today.
So at video stores whip it's like you
come in and go buy a cracker,
a balloon and the easy web at a video
store.
That's how popular was in Columbus.
So what is it?
What is it?
There's no whip cream in it.
Done.
It's just the air.
No,
no,
it's just the air that you use,
the screw on the machines that would
pump the air out,
like to go,
you learn how to do it,
you don't shake it up,
you buy it and you don't shake it out
cause the gas rises to the top.
So you just do it right off the top when
you first do it.
I'm talking about these low content
canisters that you put in like a thing
and they put it balloons talking about
cracking the whip cream.
I never did that.
That's,
that's,
that seems more like wasting your task.
So you're talking about just some
nitrous oxide and sell.
They sell easy whips.
Where is that?
What it's called?
Nitrous oxide?
No,
two nitrogen,
I think nitric oxide.
But uh,
but yeah,
and they come in these little containers
and they come you and by the case in
each balloon then you have that metal
cracker that looks kind of like
something like a camping gear thing
where you unscrew it and you put it in,
close it,
you put the balloon on one side and you
crack it and it just fills a hole
balloon.
And then just take the blind.
Yeah.
When I was a kid,
I worked at a,
one of those,
um,
ice cream place.
It's called newports creamery.
Newport Krumrie.
They serve like cheeseburgers and shit.
I was a cook for a little while and I
got fucking horrible zits from that.
That's the nastiest,
cyber,
but also a scooped ice cream and made
ice cream Sundaes.
And we would have to go replenish the,
uh,
the containers because it would make
their own whipped cream.
Yeah.
So they had these giant fucking
containers of nitrogen and everyone was
a burnout.
They would all go back there and get it.
That's great.
I only did it once.
I didn't like it.
That was my,
I was scared of drugs days.
That was all my martial arts.
You know what that sound is,
don't you?
Helicopter.
Is that what happens when you do the,
uh,
the nitric triple starts going in waves.
You hear the incident sounds like,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
Any truth to the fact that shit
instantly makes you retarded in my.
Yeah.
It seems like it would fuck you up
hardcore,
but it's not as bad as as as dis
cleaner.
Like.
Like I also add when I couldn't find a
nitrogen,
I would get disciplined for keyboards
and stuff like that.
That shit was way worse.
I remember doing that and going,
wow,
this is horrible.
Talking about anal nitrate.
No,
no,
no.
He's talking about the spray,
the spray that you spray on keyboards,
but I don't think they have any more.
I think an air now this shit.
Yeah,
I see that.
Oh No,
not get high for us.
Don't do that.
Don't do it.
Please.
I'll just kill.
I think that's just canned air.
Yeah.
I don't
think they'd make it anymore.
Maybe not.
I don't know.
Century duster.
Maybe.
I kind of feel a little lightheaded.
So what would that do?
Duty.
You did almost the same thing as
nitrous,
but it was grocer,
like after you're done,
you're like.
It seems like it's what you're
experiencing is just oxygen being cut
out of your bloodstream and your body
almost
sky.
Thinking about how many different ways
people have sought to achieve altered
states of consciousness,
huffing paint themselves and jerking off
while they were at lingerie.
Yeah.
How about that?
I was watching the wonderful whites of
West Virginia again on the plane and uh,
one of the things that they were talking
about was Jessica and how much gasoline
he sniffed that he huffed so much
gasoline.
He could tell the difference between
regular and high test.
He doesn't have to look at the time.
And he was talking about how you have
gasoline.
10.
My strange addiction.
No,
what does that show on Tlc?
And one of the episodes is a woman is
addicted to sniffing gasoline.
I wake up in the morning,
sniffed out.
She's like super hooked on it.
So at her house is just filled with like
old bottles of gas and she's,
she spends all her money on gas.
Oh my gosh.
You just addicted to huffing gas.
She loves it.
What the fuck is that?
Is that psychological?
It must be right?
Yeah.
Because she's like,
I get addicted.
Yeah,
you can.
I mean Shit.
Watch that episode.
She's addicted or she craves it.
Kinda like that disease where you crave
and gas for 15 years.
You're crazy.
Yeah,
but what I'm saying is it become become
physically addictive,
like they think that amy winehouse,
one of the speculations and amy
winehouse died because she tried to quit
alcohol cold Turkey,
which can happen to people,
but they know that happens.
Council found medication in a room.
Who knows,
but you're right.
It's very possible,
but my point is that it is possible for
that to happen.
They know that that's a documentable
occurrence.
When people just quit,
they need to wean yourself off the
alcohol to stressing your system to just
quit.
You can kill you.
That's amazing.
Delirium,
tremens,
you're losing eight and you die and it's
probably.
It's probably several drugs and shit
like that.
Very addictive drugs that are like.
There's antidepressants that if you get
off of yield,
you'll get vertigo.
Do have you seen the fucking commercials
for that Game Deuce?
Do something x than Walmart,
like people cyborgs and it's a new video
game.
What the fuck,
man,
I watched that.
It's an insane.
Those x x think that's how you say it,
but yeah,
that's a really old game man.
And this is uh,
the newest version of this really old
concept that was like a really wicked
game if I remember.
It was made by the same guys that made
Dika Catana.
There was like this faction of ids
software that broke off and there was
this character,
I think his name is Romero.
And He,
he started this company and they made
two games.
One of them had all this hype behind.
It was called dikw autonomy and I
thought it was pretty bad ass.
It was great.
Like death match style.
He was like a quake.
One Guy,
he was with quake from the very
beginning,
but this other game they made this dose
xx.
I'm pretty sure it's the same company
and this game was apparently awakened
dude fucking commercial.
Have you seen the commercial with the
cyborgs begging?
Because they are,
they're on this drug that you have to be
honoring.
Your body rejects the cybernetic part.
So it's all these people with like
Cyborg arms are like hookers with Cyborg
legs begging because they have to pay
for this medicine that you have to take
to keep the,
keep your excel falive and it's got its.
I don't know what the game plays like
is.
This seems like just pure Cgi,
like movie making.
So I don't know what the game plan.
Is this a,
is it an xbox game or a PC game?
I don't know what game a dose X.
Do you have these Weird d,
u e u x or d?
It's gotten checks in it.
Yeah.
If you look up like I was a computer
game,
but I think they also ported it over to
something.
It was a couple of years ago.
Yeah,
it was a long one.
It's coming out this month.
The first one came out a long time ago.
I'm,
I might be confused with linking it up
with the people from China.
Sorry,
Uber nerds and Geeks.
If I've steered you wrong.
Do you remember dying autonomy?
No.
It's pretty dope.
It was fun.
It was.
It disappointing to a lot of people
because they thought that it was kind of
a derivative,
you know,
a bunch of the games that existed,
but to me it was pretty fucking fun.
Especially the death match was really
fun.
I don't need any other game.
Then starcraft you don't like like fast
twitch games like quake,
starcraft's who's fast twitch,
got all defensive,
knows how you get.
Did you notice two V,
two Gold Lake?
They got a little defensive,
right?
He did that game like starcraft,
who's fast twitch minute,
constant argument with everyone over
starcraft.
Two total dork was well for one playing
video.
Playing starcraft.
Two is like they think I'm in.
How much are you playing starcraft?
Two.
How often that?
As much as a Korean,
but not as much as the Chinaman.
Three,
three,
three games a day.
Three days.
A lot of people right now saying that
that's racist,
but he's meanwhile ladies,
gentlemen,
listen to the context of using him.
He's saying it's awesome.
Yeah.
Saying it's awesome.
Yeah,
but let's be honest.
Asians love that game.
They do.
They do,
right?
Koreans love that game,
Don't they have,
like they,
we've talked about the other things,
it's the first time
I feel like I've been able to watch
something akin to sports,
really get excited about it because they
just had this big tournament and they
have like famous players and it was
really cool to watch these two famous
players,
uh,
compete against each other and knowing
the game,
having played it,
seeing the crazy tricks they're using in
the crazy control they have over so many
variables.
It's amazing to watch.
And then it's so funny because I was
thinking like athletes of the future are
all going to be fat,
fat and Pale because like they cut to
these guys who just played this insane
game that's like required so much brain
power to control this.
And since all they do is play computers,
they're kind of emotionless.
Like you cut to like a UFC fighter after
each is knock someone out and it's like
watching Julius Caesar March into a city
that each is defeated.
It's fucking,
you're watching glory.
When you got cut to a starcraft two
fighter player who's just won a game,
it just kind of like one of them took
his shirt off because underneath that he
was wearing a shirt that was kind of
insulting and he's like,
eh.
Then walked over and shook the guy's
hand,
Oh,
good job.
And that's it.
But meanwhile they just did this crazy
thing where they were controlled.
I've never played the game of watched
the best,
uh,
don't understand what's happening so I
can appreciate it is the greatest game.
It's like,
it's like,
it's like Sim city in space.
It looks pretty crazy.
It looks like you got to do a lot of
different things and you're moving
around a lot of different shit and
you're setting things up all over the
place.
You're building the ideas,
you're building up this economy by
gathering resources and while you're
building this economy,
you're also constructing an army that
has to be based on what your opponent's
doing.
So you can't just do the same thing over
and over again.
You have to like scout what your
opponent's doing and from seeing what
they're doing.
You understand what their strategy
probably is and then you have to like
create a perfect,
a perfect offense to what they're doing
while building a defense that works
against the type of troops they're
constructing because it might not
always.
You have to be completely reactive and
you have to be able to do all of this.
Well.
It's like juggling.
You're juggling all these crazy balls at
once and you have to be able to do this
and also instantaneously react to shit
that you don't expect to happen.
Isn't it crazy that the most satisfying
game is a virtual representative of war?
Yeah,
totally.
Pretty much all our.
Yeah.
Isn't that amazing?
Well,
that battlefield earth call of duty
quake,
Mario Brothers,
unreal tournament.
The Mario or some sort of a futuristic
or you know,
ancient or either like world war two or
something like the words fucking
futuristic something.
Yeah.
What the fuck.
You read that book war by Sebastian
younger where there isn't a square.
He does is he describes what that's like
to be behind a fucking machine gun
blasting people like he does this
incredible description of it and the
adrenaline that that creates is like
amazing,
but I'll tell you something else that
creates adrenaline.
When I do attend pool rush into my
opponent's face and my fucking speed
links in circle is base and devour it.
Only she and then he has the audacity to
text me and say that I was doing cheese
moves.
That's the greatest feeling ever.
I see it and believe it and I think that
if I got into it,
I'd fucking love it too much and you
would go there.
Now I got a deleted it.
I'm deleting it tomorrow.
I think pool for me is a form of
like a moving meditation.
When I'm running out,
when I played pool,
it's.
I'm using my body as well and that's one
of the things that I like about the most
that I'm forcing my mind to control the
exact amount of forest my body exerts on
a piece of wood that impacts a ball that
collides and into another ball and moves
around.
In order to do it right,
I have to be in total tune with the
amount of revolutions and causing this
ball to turn over a nine foot table.
I mean that's what I'm trying to
control.
So to get like into that like real
groove of being like dead stroke where
you really feel the movement.
It really is like a form of meditation.
So that's why I prefer it over video
games.
I had to pick my poison,
I had to pick like what thing am I
allowing myself to be addicted to and
that I think I get more out of the pool
than I did out of the video games.
The Video Games was fun as fuck man,
I love him to this day but I can't play
you.
We played any of the connect games like
there's a game right now called child of
Eden.
Have you fucking smoke some good weed or
take some shrooms and stand in front of
that game?
You will fucking feel like you're doing
virtual.
If I'm alone at home,
I'll fire up gears a war for a goof.
Just go on a fucking rampage because
it's fun because it's just.
The graphics are so dope,
so wild.
Seeing these fucking monsters they've
created.
I'll do that for fun on the big screen,
but yeah man,
you got to moderate it.
That's a province so fucking addictive
and it's so easy to lose your mind to
get lost in it
really just lost,
but yet it's so fucking fun.
And what?
Who's to say that that fund is less real
than the fun that you get actually out
there playing basketball then?
Oh,
I'll say it.
Yeah,
me too.
I think it's less real,
but why?
What if you're in tune and dominating
you?
Why?
Because when I get done with an
addictive session of world of warcraft
and I've been playing,
or I'm sorry,
I used to be addicted to that.
You started to starcraft two.
When I get up after playing that game
for like three or four hours straight
and walk outside,
I feel like I feel like I'm like a
mentally disabled.
I feel drained.
My sleep sucks when I fucking,
you know,
uh,
go to the gym or go jogging or do
something like that.
I feel great for the rest of the day.
So video games are amazing and weirdly
games that involve strategy,
I think you can extrapolate some
information from that that you can use
in real life,
but you got to do it in very small
doses.
It's like that.
That seems like the responsibility of
human beings.
We've got this incredible brand new
technology that's exploding in front of
us.
The discipline is not to reject it.
Totally like those assholes.
When you hear,
I don't even have cell phone,
it's not to reject it.
The idea is that moderate at learn how
to use it,
like a tool.
How do you do it?
That's what every.
It's like when I said I was addicted to
it,
city of heroes,
I used to always fantasize about jumping
on from building the building just
because I had been playing that video
game so much and that was something I
was doing repetitively
all day,
all night.
If you
dropped me off in the middle of a castle
and they look like the scenes from quake
one,
I might start pretending I started
talking like one of those quick cuts
running down hallways with rocket
launchers.
Talking as usual.
Yes,
you're the best.
You're the best man.
You are those too much fun.
Too Much to interesting and I'm going to
enjoy all the taped phone conversations
that the FBI will be tuning into myself.
Ideas here,
ready to get bored.
FBI conversations.
My phone conversations suck.
Have Fun with that.
Thank you to the fleshlight for
sponsoring the podcast.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the
flashlight,
enter the code name Rogan,
and you will get 15 percent off the
number one sex toy for men.
Thank you everybody who came out to the
show in Milwaukee.
Thanks to everybody who's saying happy
birthday.
To me,
that was one of the coolest things that
I've ever had happened in my life.
It was pretty fun.
Uh,
Milwaukee was the shit.
I had a great time.
Next,
a big road gig is Denver,
Colorado.
September 23rd at the paramount theater.
And that's me and Joey motherfucking dee
is not,
it's not a new orleans.
Is New Orleans in between that September
23rd one is New Orleans.
Uh,
it is what I'll tell you right now.
Do,
do,
do the 16th of September a nine.
16 to September.
Okay.
So there nine slash 16.
Two thousand 11.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'll be at the house of Blues and New
Orleans and this,
some of the get there early because some
people are gonna have to stand up.
Unfortunately there was no other way I
could get a show there.
There's another place you not get the
standup states you will hate.
It sucks.
It sucks standing out.
But I'll try to be as energetic as
possible.
And I instituted a policy when Brian and
I went to see doug stanhope when we
enjoyed the fuck out of Stan hope as
always,
but it wasn't fun to stand and watch a
show.
So I decided,
you know,
what I'm being brewed,
asking people stand and watch my shows.
Like from now on,
I'm going to make sure that every show I
do,
people are seated,
but there was no places in town,
there was nothing I could do.
There was like small places that were
like 50 seats or um,
you know,
the House of Blues.
So we're going to do the house of Blues
and it's a rare seating and standing
show.
And that's September blonde,
blue eyed girl Joe Rogan dot map for
details.
All right.
Can you provide some windows show?
Fuck yeah,
I'm in La Tonight.
Laugh have factory tomorrow night.
What time?
Comedy store?
Thursday.
The improv going to one of these shows
and say hi,
please.
Yeah,
please do.
And uh,
Brian,
what is this?
You're doing the show
the info.
I'll be at the improv tonight at 10:00.
And have you used the code?
Coupon Code Red?
You get free tickets.
I'm gonna.
Retweet that shit right now.
If anybody is interested and you want to
go heckle Brian and you don't get real
Ninja up there.
All right.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
We've got to figure out when the.
Hopefully I'm going to get Kevin Smith
for the rest of this weekend.
We've got to make nice,
nice with Jay,
more Brian and Jay Morehead issues,
but Jay Morris being very nice about it
so we,
we must in the spirit of forgiveness and
peacefulness,
bring him on and he's a very talented
guy anyway.
All right,
that's it.
That's the end of the show.
I love you guys and thank you very much
for everything and ain't go fuck
yourselves about that being too nice to
you.
Getting soft again.
Soft.
Love you guys.
Thank you very much.
Bye.